welcome ladies and gentlemen we're
coming to you live from the Heritage
Foundation HQ hanging out after the
premiere of police state at thees soza
film it was uh uh it looked pretty
amazing the event and everything that's
going on so we'll be talking about that
but the big news right now is uh it's
fairly cultural but it has to do of
course with Israel Palestine Ben Shapiro
has just publicly told Candace Owens to
quit the daily wire if she has a problem
with taking money from them and this is
uh well it's resulted in them being I
guess the biggest trend on Twitter right
now and it's going to get interesting
because Mike cernovich calls this um
constructive termination which is a
legal term and uh well there's some
there's some talk about what this uh
what this could lead to there is a a new
episode of Tucker Carlson where Candace
ens has responded to Ben Shapiro's
criticism of her where Ben said she was
being disgraceful over position related
to Israel and Palestine so we're going
to talk a lot about that plus we've got
news out of Atlanta relating to antifa
setting fire to a bunch of construction
vehicles 61 State racketeering charges
but that's the key there State charges
and we're going to talk about what's
going on in this country with the police
state because surprise surprise these
are not federal charges before we get
started my friends head over to cast
brew.com and buy the best cup of coffee
you've ever had you can pick it up today
we've got our limited edition rise with
rise sorry with Roberto Jr our Hollywood
SPO Hollywood Halloween spoof Edition
where we have our dead mascot rooster
his foot emerging from the ground
because I guess we're not being
respectful to him but uh if you want to
support our cultural Endeavors which is
physical coffee shop locations this is
the beginning of the project I was tired
of waiting around the coffee shop is
being built and so we are currently
selling the coffee pick up your
appalachin nights pick up your rise with
Roberto Jr and your stand your grounds
we got K Cups we got whole bean we got
ground brew.com but also don't forget go
to timcast.net
brutal drive back to West Virginia from
DC and it's just quite literally
impossible for us to to actually arrange
that so apologies on that uh and but if
you haven't already become a member to
watch INF Fringe you don't want to miss
it smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show right now
everywhere you can if you would like to
support the work that we do we got a
couple really great guests joining us we
have Des do soza and Julie Kelly dases
do you want to introduce yourself sure
I'm a um I'm a writer I'm a filmmaker
and uh of course the latest film police
state the website is policestate fm.net
the film was in theaters rave reviews
but now it's in streaming it's also in
DVD uh you won't get it at Walmart or
Amazon because they're not letting us
sell it there but you can go to
policestate fm.net and load up for
Christmas right on Julie Kelly would you
like to introduce yourself hi I'm Julie
Kelly fellow chicagoan Tim pool even
though he thinks I I could hear it in
your voice even says because I'm from
neille and he did that's true I I I
yelled at her I screamed ah wait where
are you from originally I am actually
from the same neighborhood as Tim but we
moved out of the city I'm mostly from
the suburbs like I'm I'm giving you a
hard time you want me to dox myself
right now I'm going to tell the whole
world I'm going to give my address want
me to put it all on a silver platter for
Ana right now can I guess absolutely not
no because that's just as bad Midway uh
Julie okay I know the neighborhood I
know the neighborhood that's not a
suburb uh Julie Kelly Declassified at
Julie Kelly on substack also real clear
investigations you speak closer to the
mic yeah yeah you got to get up right
into that microphone sorry okay is that
good and uh I have a podcast with Liz
sheld who is here happy hour with Liz
sheld and on Twitter a lot right on we
got Phil and anair hanging out hello I
am Phil leonti very failed singer of All
That Remains uh anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary yeah and I'm Hannah
Clair brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net culture War kittens I've
missed you all so much I'm happy to be
back here for another show listen my
fans voted that that's what they wanted
to be called so that's what I'm calling
them yes I do believe it or not some
people watch me and it's not just
because they hate me yeah yeah believe
it or not but I'm glad to be back I've
missed all of you I'm Sheamus cogin I am
a political cartoonist and commentator I
have a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes where we upload a cartoon every
single Thursday lampooning current
events or sometimes just getting into
culture War issues in a deeper way
rather than touching on current events
tomorrow's video is going to be very
very funny in my humble opinion and next
week's video is going to be a
Thanksgiving special that let's just say
we're very excited for so I want to ask
you all to subscribe at Freedom Tunes
check our stuff out hit the notification
Bell we got some good stuff coming at
you tomorrow and next week it will be
Thanksgiving not friends giving correct
no AB we don't do the friends giving
thing I'm not cuz I don't have any I
don't have any so that's why I don't do
fans giving either apparently today sh
sent me a Bible verse telling me that
women should stop talking so that's
actually not what happen that's not true
doent me she sent me something
condescendingly saying that she could
teach me a lesson and so I sent her
first timothy2 just try personal we have
to get this show I'm not particularly
religious but I kind of like the the
attitude at least I'll send it to you
it's Charming let's get into I was
sending an out of context verse to be
chish with Sheamus you are acting very
unprofessionally right now and you're
you've been emotionally unhinged for
weeks I know so we've all had to put up
with it okay I'm kidding by the way I'm
just reading K's tweet I would have done
an after show by the way just so you
guys know Tim was like it's going to be
hard to drive back I said let's do the I
told everyone else to do it and everyone
looked at me like I was the devil I have
a dog that I have to take care of she's
going to be in the kennel for how about
we talk about news everybody the first
story that we got is a tweet from Ben
Shapiro who says Candice if you feel
that taking money from the daily wire
somehow comes between you and God by all
means quit and that is a bold response
to Candis owens's tweet which is my
understanding is a Bible verse but jamus
might be better versed with this she uh
Candace Owens tweeted blessed are the
peacemakers for they shall be called the
children of God blessed are they which
are persecuted for righteous
righteousness' sake for theirs is the
Kingdom of Heaven blessed are ye when
men shall revile you and persecute you
and shall say all manner of evil against
you falsely for my sake no one can serve
two masters either you will hate the one
and love the other or you will be
devoted to one and despise the other you
cannot serve both God and money in
response to this Ben said by all means
quit to which Candice replied you have
you have been acting unprofessional and
emotionally unhinged for weeks now and
we have all had to sit back and allow it
and have all tried to exercise exceeding
understanding for your raw emotion but
you cross a certain line when you come
for scripture and read yourself into it
I will not tolerate it so needless to
say things are getting rather
interesting and if you're wondering why
they're fighting what this all about it
has to do with Israel Palestine recently
Ben Shapiro was seen on video saying
that Candace owens's Fox sophistication
was disgraceful as it pertained to what
was going on and cenace Owens has a
video where she M she said that her
point was simply why are we so concerned
about what's going on in Israel when our
own universities are teaching children
at young people to demonize white people
why are we spending so much money and
energy on foreign countries when we
should be securing our borders and
helping the American people and I I'm
like yeah I I agree with Candace on that
for that Candace tweets this blessed are
the peacemakers which is to imply
perhaps ceasefire and that's what a lot
of people are reading into it Ben of
course has just told to quit and now
we've got uh I think I actually have
this tweet from Mike cernovich let's see
if I can uh pull this up Mike cernovich
uh well we've got a couple actually
here's Tucker Carlson and where's the
Mike cernovich one okay I guess I might
not have it but Mike cernovich said it
was constructive termination which is
basically when you create a a pressure
in your company that is so they're going
to have to quit a single instance can do
this Jack pic says Candace Owens
Compares Ben to a BLM activist who
accuses someone of being racist if they
don't support defunding the police and
Mike cernovich said he's become
indistinguishable from a far leftwing
identity politics woke psycho he's
working the soft cancel culture Angle
now I didn't fire Candace she quit but
he should also look up what constructive
termination is so uh let's just get into
it I don't know this is the big story
how you guys doing anybody I mean why
don't we have any fun drama I don't
understand anybody that go like as far
as like C covich's uh covich covic
whatever his critic M um anyone that
touches on identity politics starts to
sound like the people you know whether
they intend to or not they're going to
sound like they're diving into identity
politics whether it be you know white
people talking about their whiteness or
or whatever or if you're complaining
about white people in whiteness or
whatever anytime you touch that you you
can't help but sound like the people
that are like leftists yeah like they're
like you're leftist like you're a victim
like you you need some kind of special
accommodation because people are
offending you for talking about about
that and it doesn't matter who does it
it doesn't matter whether it's a Jewish
person a white person a black person it
doesn't matter that's just the way you
come off when you when you go into that
area I got an issue what I I wouldn't
describe as a hard journalistic
correction but a failed um what's the
right right word in a failed Insight on
my part I said the other day that
Candace and Ben arguing over this stuff
and having a kind of a public spat is
just good for the daily wire it's press
attention which is true and that it
probably wouldn't go beyond this they're
going to criticize each other and then
but now Ben's telling her to quit which
I don't know if like if you guys have
legal expertise to some degree but it
seems to me that if you have a contract
with someone and then you publicly say
you should quit you've just given them
legal recourse to terminate their
contract you know I think what's going
on here is that um daily wire is a
fom and they like to have kind of a
stable of people in their team
but who are completely under their thumb
uh remember the Crowder business which
happened not that long ago and I thought
it was so odd because what what appear
to be a private negotiation suddenly
erupts into public well why well
apparently what Crowder was was kind of
um Bing against was the idea of quote
being owned by the daily wire right and
and I think this is what's going on here
is that Candace is a very independent
spirit she's actually got a pretty good
ego she wants to be her own person and
yet somehow she's coralled into the
daily wire stable and they expect her to
quote behave and she doesn't really
think she needs to she's Candice she
doesn't need to she doesn't need to and
so I see this as a kind of I mean you
could have had the philosophical debate
without this acrimony so it's very
interesting that the two have become
conflated but do you think Ben Shapiro
could have had the philosophical debate
without the emotion behind it because
it's so much tied to his core identity
and how he views the world maybe Candace
could have because she's a little bit
more removed but someone who's tied to
the religious and ethnic groups that are
involved it's it's much harder well I
think that is right I mean I do think
that this is the make or break issue for
Ben I think it is the lens through which
other issues are filtered uh and also
even if you take a position that said
something like you know uh this is
anti-israel but it's not necessarily
anti-Semitism boom you've like violated
the taboo you're like suddenly on the
outs so I think this is a case where in
Daily wire a relative lock step is being
demanded uh and Candice just won't play
along with that and so you've got this
public spat um and I assume this happens
at all major media companies right I'm
sure fox has had the same issues as it's
grown there are some people who feel as
though they can't question their boss on
on certain issues well I mean the thing
about it is you know you want to be
clear in advance about what you stand
for so if daily wi were basically say
listen we want a variety of views but
kind of no variety on this one topic
this is kind of a a bright line for us
then you wouldn't join daily wire if you
intended to step out of line but it
looks to me like what happened with
daily wire was that they were like let's
get some really big personalities into
our tent um and and even the phrase that
was used in the context of crowder wage
slavery which is kind of an old phrase
out of Marx in the 19th century that's
what really rankled Crowder because he's
like you know I'm not going to be your
slave you know you might pay me well but
nevertheless I'm still my own man and I
think something I I hear the same Echo
here I got to I got to I got to tell you
man you know when the Crowder thing went
down I brought up how we had
negotiations with the guys at the daily
wire and I think they're fantastic the
the negotiations and the conversations
that I had with co-ceo Jeremy boring
were probably the most refreshing
business negotiations I've ever had in
any circumstance where I felt like he
wasn't lying to me and I respect that
tremendously I'm not kidding man when
I've met with these big podcast
companies back like several years ago
when I've met with uh big corporate news
they're they're blown smoke up your you
get what I'm saying I sit down with
Jeremy and it was like a real
conversation about what's going on what
we could do why we could do it and you
know what ultimately came down to is uh
I don't know that I could do a deal like
this because I'm kind of a guy and I
might want to buy a billboard that says
you know Liz Cheney is a fat pig or
something like that and they chuckled
and they were like Fair Point Fair Point
you know and so I don't know if I
mentioned that before I think I did
because I was like I would like to
insult people like warmongers who I
greatly despise you know I do get a lot
of people saying no they'll never come
on your show Tim don't you get it and
I'm like well you know I guess it's if
like Liz Cheney was going to come do Tim
cast and subject herself to a two-hour
interview where she was asked tough
questions about the things she's been
involved with that was ever going to
happen so but btim comes down to this
like I saw this outright when I sit down
with them and they're like what what are
what are the potentials that we have cuz
they're like we love what you do and
then I was like and I'm a fan of what
daily wire does especially in the
culture war and then ultimately it came
down to one simple question of obviously
like money plays a role but daily wire
is is flush with cash but the the real
issue is look man I'm going to take my
money and I'm do weird things with it
I'm I'm going to do uh uh uh I want I
want a culture Jam I want to I want to
shock the system I want to say things
that are offensive and they were like
fair point then you know we'll we'll
work on things but we'll keep it we'll
we we'll keep it professionalized I cool
I mean whenever you're an institution of
any kind you're subject to the
institution its investors its donors I
mean I've been at the American
Enterprise Institute the Hoover
institution it always occurred to me
that I have a measure of Independence
because when you're in a think tank
basically they pay you to do whatever
you want Tes write books give speeches
and so I was like this is the best gig
ever but I realized well how ises AI
funded well they're funded by
corporations they're funded by a handful
of big donors you you can't run ath
those guys because then there's someone
to complain to and if you become a
liability they're going to offload you I
I do want to mention because you know I
see like super chats where they're
saying I'm with Candace on this one I'm
I'm like that's the beauty of the daily
wire though they've got you choosing
sides the daily wire the daily wire
unless of course Candace does quit and
and and that would be I think that would
be like a nuclear bomb going off for the
daily wire if Candace actually leaves
I'm hoping that this is just like kind
of half-thought stunt of some sort like
Candace really is a that Will Smith you
mean you think it's a it's a variation
of the Hollywood uh production yep like
you know who who did Will Smith slap was
it Chris Rock Chris CHR Rock but then it
turns out he wasn't even with his wife
JIS right came out was like we've been
separated for a hundred years that's so
gross it just makes the whole thing
worse I mean I think the this fight or
this dispute online is going to be
something Progressive media Outlets try
and sorry Serge uh Progressive media
Outlets try and capitalize on as look
these right-wing Enterprises are are
fracturing they're falling apart to
direct from the fact that they also have
a lot of issues yeah the the the Israeli
Palestine conflict is is splitting both
the left and the right and really making
people pick sides I imagine that Candace
doesn't have a strong I imagine it would
make sense to think that Candice doesn't
have as strong of an opinion as as Ben
obviously because Ben's got family in
Israel you know so she's americ she
could have a strong opinion that America
shouldn't spend money on Foreign Wars
yeah I think that I think Ben looks the
whole thing is beyond that yeah we're
living in a time and this is not the way
things used to be but where institutions
tend to be defined by one guy uh even if
you go back to the Old National Review
was Bill Buckley there a lot of other
guys around him but like it's Buckley's
magazine commentary was Norman put
hord's magazine and uh you know this is
the tempool
operation fam
operation not a lot of people know that
I got dis of media and so I think what
happens at Daily wire is it is Ben
Shapiro but then you've got these other
guys who are kind of luminaries in their
own right and so now the issue of is a
little unclear who's the brand but you
know it's really simple actually if you
look at all of their personalities
they're homegrown but Candace Owens was
recruited Candace Owens was already big
was already popular was already uh
moving politically like in Jord Peterson
actually well right right right right
yeah so but you know like nolles and
claven these are their homegrown
personalities that they've built up Matt
Walsh and they've done a tremendous job
in in in getting attention and building
influence for their for their hosts but
uh was Michael nolles worked for the
company and then you know has now become
one of the biggest social social and
political commentators well I I kind of
want to touch on something that you
mentioned earlier toes you said that the
dailywire grabs different people so that
they can have a large tent reach a broad
audience and have a lot of different
influencers I think that's true and I
think interestingly enough that's
actually symbolic of a broader issue
with the conservative movement which is
we've tried to welcome everybody into
the tent and we actually don't have
principles or know how to define
ourselves anymore as a result of that so
when it comes to the Israel Palestine
conflict obviously that's something
where I think there can be diversity of
opinion but there are so many social
issues issues like abortion
homosexuality um lgbtq issues more
broadly speaking where the right doesn't
even know what it believes because we've
expanded the tent out to everybody who
the left has said they don't like and so
we've actually allowed our enemies to
decide what our movement is I don't
disagree with that but I think generally
American American culture is very
ambiguous we don't have a defined
cultural identity that people
theoretically could assimilate to so it
becomes difficult to say where any lines
are and then you add policy on top of
that you don't think America had like a
broad overarching culture I think we
could and we did it one point but I
think as it stands right now Americans
are very resistant to cultivating
American culture I mean think about
everyone who was like if Trump gets
elected I will move to Canada like
there's all kinds of resistance to being
American if that's how our young people
feel then we have failed as a culture to
maintain a cultural identity young
people in the United States a lot of the
people that I end up working with when
I'm like touring and stuff like that
younger people really don't they want to
avoid the Nationalist uh idea and that
comes or just patriotism well that
that's what they they see patriotism as
nationalism they see American flags and
they are they're turned off by it and
some people that I'm really really close
to and that that I have a really great
relationship with they don't see a a
love of country as something that's
important they think of themselves as
Global and I do understand that that's a
little bit more of the that is that is
probably because of the people that I'm
around they they travel around the world
they're they're you know playing
concerts and and performing in places
all over the world so that does make
people feel less connected to a an
individual place but it is something
that is that is true among younger
people in the United States and I think
that it's partially because we've we
have between the Gen X and and possibly
the Millennials they didn't instill a
pride in young people and they didn't
really you know Civics was taken out of
school and stuff and people don't
understand why America is special and
what about our government system is
special and why it's why it should be
preserved and you you add to that that
the younger Generations I mean the
millennial generation my generation and
gen Z and gen Alpha are growing up in a
world where everything is being handed
to you and I don't mean everything but
your bare necessities now I get it
expand beyond that is becoming
increasingly difficult owning a home is
becoming increasingly difficult but when
your whole life is playing with your
friends going to school coming home and
eating Rice Krispie squares or whatever
and Tang from your mom and it's not
having to chop wood otherwise you're
freeze to death in the winter we are we
are building multiple generations of
people who don't know what it takes to
survive and that breeds entitlement and
resentment and without any any sense of
community it's that's antifa it's chaos
it's the far left it's the woke cult
well I think we've also manufactured
quite a lot of C uh cynicism some
intentionally and some otherwise so just
to speak to my own experience people in
my generation can probably relate to
this I was six when 911 happened and
immediately there were just American
flags everywhere everyone was talking
about patriotism and coming together as
a country and then what that was used
for was basically to push for these wars
that basically everybody now looks back
on and says we're bad for the country so
for a lot of people in my demographic
their first introduction to patriotism
and to love of country was abused in
such a way to give handouts to the
industrial military complex and do
things that ultimately were not good for
the country so people are less willing
to come on board with common projects
that actually are good for the nation I
want that's not new I mean young people
young people being disillusioned with
America uh and the flag and not being
patriotic it's it's not really that new
I mean we're gen xers and we were raised
in the 80s and we had Ronald Reagan and
I think we were raised in a certain era
of Greater Patriot ISM but there still
was a big contingent who thought that
Ronald Reagan was more evil than the
Soviet
Union did so so this is I mean has to be
put in going downhill you well because
yeah and I mean I think Academia is and
I mean desesa wrote the book on it a
liberal education was one of the first
books that opened my eyes about what
they're indoctrinating kids with and now
when you have your own children in
college you really see it but I I do
think things need to be put in context a
little because what they said about
Trump they said about Ronald Reagan you
know there was a brief window where GE W
Bush was a hero and then all of a sudden
you know he's we had the Vietnam War and
there was a massive young people's
revolt against that and then Reagan came
along and and Reagan found a middle
ground that has suddenly somehow been
lost uh the middle ground was called the
Reagan Doctrine so the rean Doctrine is
that people must fight for their own
Freedom we don't fight for them it's
their country they fight we help so the
classic model of this was the Soviets
invade Afghanistan they occupied with
100,000 troops they're all these Afghan
mujahid Iden who want to fight back
Reagan's like I'm not sending a single
soldier but I'll send some CIA advisors
I'll give you some Stinger Rockets to
shoot down some Soviet helicopters and
and the beauty of this was that it
allowed that kind of libertarian desire
to have freedom spread worldwide but
without a kind of costly deployment and
extended deployment of troops and then
once the Iraq war came along we went to
preemptive War we went to what did those
guys have to do with 9/11 we went to the
idiotic you know where did that come out
of a store like if you if you break it
you own it what you know if you get rid
of a of a dictator of a country you now
have the job of rebuilding the country
what so all this kind of Madness this is
almost like neoconservatism gone berserk
but but Reagan was never on board with
any of this I want to I want to jump to
the story from the SF Chronicle David
deap describes far-right conspiracies
that led him to Pelosi house that's
right this is the guy who attacked Paul
Pelosi and he testified the other day
these stories went wild he was claiming
that he wanted to get Nancy Pelosi to
confess on camera while he wore a
unicorn costume and then he wanted Biden
to Pardon her for these crimes which is
a just a all all around the dude's
clearly unwell but uh who do you think
they're blaming for for all of this in
all of these new comment sections and on
leftist Twitter and all these chats I
that sounds like something Ian would say
the the the the unicorn unicorn costume
and then get the president to to and and
uh uh I you know I want to say that um
this is a guy who wanted Joe Biden to
Pardon Nancy Pelosi let me read the
story they say David deap the man
accused of attacking Paul Pelosi with a
hammer in San Francisco last year
testified in his federal trial Tuesday
offering the most detailed Glimpse to
date into the motivations and
conspiracies that drove him to embark on
what he said he and his lawyers
described as a mission to fix a world
corrupted by democrats under questioning
from his own attorney toap sketched the
Contours of his worldview and his
political leanings both of which were
heavily informed by conservative media
personnels and podcasters David deap
testified that he subscribed to a number
of baseless and wildly discredited
conspiracy theories many of which
revolved around assertation of cabals of
high ranking public officials and
celebrities harming children
uh yada yada he says he used to be
leftwing and I wonder if the chronicle
actually removed the references but uh
to a search yeah did it I think they
might have taken it out maybe they were
scared that we were going to sue him uh
did I get did I make the cut okay here
we go I'm s I'm sorry I'm sorry here
here it is we're here we're here he
turned instead to conservative
commentators Tim p and James Lindsay
deap said he also went on to mention
many others he mentioned Glenn backck
and other channels but I just want to
shout out uh depending on which news
Outlet you read they'll choose
selectively which person he claimed to
have been listening to and uh Tim p and
James Lindsay and I am offended by this
because as Phil pointed out the
demanding Joe Biden pardon the Democrats
yeah that's all for that's all Ian Ian
what are you doing you getting me in
trouble over here as soon as I as soon
as I heard this I was like he didn't pay
attention to anything Tim said that's
all Ian crossin famous far right
commenter Ian CR the same thing happened
to me though they gave one of my quotes
to Ian they get all of his quotes
screwed up yeah who was it Media Matters
who CL that your quote was Ian it was I
think it was Gawker and I was talking
about how horribly destructive no fault
divorce is and they said Ian crossin
said it like that's that's not was like
clearly something I would say and
they're like Ian crossin said but they
don't watch the show enough right they
don't know who any of you guys are so so
this is a guy who committed a horrible
attack you know on Paul Pelosi these
things shouldn't happen they need better
security and uh they're claiming oh he
was watching you know my show whatever
and and I saw this story I thought it
was funny medium matters quoted me the
last time when the guy in Texas posted
four clips from IRL and the quote is Tim
Po says I think it's funny and I just
don't care or something like that and
I'm like yeah dude look there will not
be a single person who can ever ever get
me to care that some dude W some dude
who did some bad thing watched my show
we get millions upon Millions that's
insane the idea that James F first of
all I want to shout out conservative
commentator James Lindsay I mean which
is laughable up Jim SU gy yeah and uh
but I but one thing I really love about
Ian crand who's not here unfortunately
tonight um the thing that's great about
him is he's he's a weird guy he doesn't
fit in any political box his opinions
are wild he's for the death penalty he's
like very much for it we had this big
conversation where he was like what we
got to get you know got to have the
death penalty for these people and I'm
like whoa but then he's like but we got
to Pardon all Hillary Clinton and I'm
just like he's kind of wild but the he
helps break the machine because when
Gawker takes a quote from Sheamus and
applies it to Ian or when Hassan perer
claims Ian is a conservative it shows
you that they're they're they're complet
their arguments are meaningless
completely empty I I don't think we
should take this at face value Julie of
course has been following the January 6
trials and you know Julie that there are
many cases where at the coaching of
attorneys the the guy who had one motive
is coached into a different storyline
that is made palatable for the media
palatable for the jury palatable for the
judge to show compassion so what I see
here is a leftist who has now realized
that uh moving right and claiming to be
under the right-wing spell will suddenly
get him a lot of sympathetic attention
uh sing lower sentencing uh yeah the
conservatives drove him crazy well and
this guy is an illegal immigrant from
Canada who voted for the green party I
mean this is why they had to construct
The Narrative and that's why they needed
a migration because they know he started
left so they had to account for that
probably still is and probably still is
this proves it it's just one big
conspiracy against me I'm the victim
here you are the center of the universe
I'm the victim CU I'm paragraph there
talking about Gail ruin at the very end
it says uh talking about particularly on
pedophilia and sexual relationships have
been misconstrued nothing that Gail
Rubin that that that James Lindsay has
said about Gail rubin's writings none of
it has been misconstrued it is all word
for word stuff that she has written in
her books and let me drive it home I
don't I don't know about where this guy
gets his ideas or or anything like that
I will say it's certainly that Tim pool
idea to Pardon corrupt politicians but
they bring up Gail Rubin in this why she
has nothing to do with the pelis the
this man going to to the Pelosi's house
and wanting to attack or harm Pelosi has
nothing to do with James Lindsay or Gail
Rubin it does seem like what you said
toes that hey look I bet his defense
attorneys said here's what you're going
to do you're in San Francisco this is
the jury you got to claim it's the
rightwing that radicalized you attack
James Lindsay Glenn Beck Tim p and
there's a few others they mentioned and
uh then you'll get lesser charges
they'll use that to weave a narrative I
mean Julie hasn't this exactly been the
January 6th not in some cases the where
the courta appointed attorneys have
lured the defendants into this kind of
whole therapeutic I used to be a
trumpster I've now realized that he
deceived
me Alis said right if I had known what
when she said that she was going to
plead guilty in Georgia she said if I
had known what I know now I would never
have acted that way I mean it's like
renounce everything you've ever done and
throw yourself on the mercy of these
completely biased juries we're having
conversation right now had they've had
they do have struggle session still
ongoing and you had a public defender um
um Heather Shaner who's represented
several January 6 defendants and she
actually gives them a list of books and
movies to
read to forgive themselves for their
white privilege and then they will go to
the judge and they'll write an apology
letter or they will apolog you know tell
the judge in a letter or verbally you
know I didn't realize how racist and uh
anti-semitic and we killed all the
Native Americans and uh so these are the
defendent my own campaign Finance case
think about this I give money to Wendy
long who's running college friend of
mine and the judge this is the part I
want to focus on as part of my sentence
psychiatric counseling as if my behavior
is so inexplicable it
demands psychiatric therapy but see I
think what they were getting at is had I
gone through the psychological
counseling eight months and I had come
out and sort of seen the light and I
realize I'm actually now a leftist and
I'm now applying for like a job on
MSNBC I would have been declared cured
can I wouldn't that be hilarious if you
actually did that just to troll the
system if you're like no yeah I'm a
leftist and got a job on MSNBC and then
their highest rated host was someone who
was re-educated into being a leftist
here's here's a point that I want to
make about this case that I think
everyone needs to ask themselves as
denes pointed out and and as mentioned
uh Julie Kelly in your work January
Sixers are given this narrative why
would a criminal defendant
go on the stand for several hours and
explain that the crime he committed was
actually part of a much much larger
conspiracy and that he actually was
attempting several more crimes for what
purpose would the CL would this
defendant be advantaged by admitting to
further criminal conspiracy on the
stand I mean he's obviously
theoretically going to help the state
with something there's no way that he
counsel to do that unless they
potentially could throw some my point
there's no legitimate legal circumstance
St where they're like go up there and
admit to doing more crimes admit to
having wanting to do more crimes unless
the narrative was how can we rope in
right-wing conspiracy stuff so you have
a guy who attacked Paul Pelosi and
that's the story he was a leftist he was
a green party guy he was Canadian they
want to weave this into a story about
the far right but how do you he attacked
Paul Pelosi well of course the Pelosi
are there so then he has to go on and
say well Nome and Gail Rubin were
targets too so you're admitting to
wanting to do more crimes to create The
Narrative that's right yeah my guess is
this guy is out of his mind and they
realize that they could now move him
like a puppet in whatever Direction they
they wanted to and so they've
constructed a narrative I I I think it
might be simple enough that as defense
came to and said look you're in San
Francisco it is as blue as blue can be
you attacked the leader of the
democratic party's husband you need to
shift this politically and this is a
scary thing for what's happening in this
country well keep in mind too excuse me
uh Tim but the US capital police the
same organization that allowed the
capital to be left unsecured on January
6 they were monitoring the Pelosi
property in real time so they've
expanded their offices out of Washington
they shouldn't to parts of Florida and
California so they were monitoring and
they said oh we just looked away and
whatever then all of a sudden this guy
bursts into the house breaks into the
house so it's also part of to your to
your point you're right but also so
covering up again another agency that
really should be disbanded Congress
shouldn't have their own police force
not only are they protecting that not
protecting in this case uh but they're
totally incompetent should be disbanded
and they're they're once again trying to
cover up what they did wrong we had a
legal issue uh year or so ago so I call
my lawyer and I say hey we've got we've
got this legal dispute civil not
criminal and a civil tort of some sort
and he said uh okay well if we Sue in uh
uh in California we lose instantly if we
Sue in New York we lose instantly
instantly because these were big uh
media corporations that we were looking
at and he goes so obviously we're going
to try and do it in West Virginia which
means we need to figure out why we have
standing to be in West Virginia to do it
and I laughed and I was like I totally
get it and he goes look man you get a
judge in New York and they're going to
be corporate and they're going to be
Democrats and they instantly hate you no
matter what you say because you're Tim
pool you go to West Virginia and
probably going to instantly like you I
got to be honest you file in West
Virginia the judge is going to side with
you no matter what you say and I'm like
that's crazy but that's the reality of
where we are with this political
bifurcation absolutely outside of any
Grand conspiracy or narrative crafting
or whatever we want to say may have
happened I think his defense lawyers
just said look man pretend that tell
everyone that it's the evil Boogeyman
far right that made you do it and cross
your fingers well you know you mentioned
earlier Jenna Ellis and um and part of
what's going on here is that the plea
bargain system has become a legal
bludgeon um in which they come to you
and in effect say we can get something
on you no matter what and and now what
they do is they because of the large
Federal accordion of statutes they can
redescribe the same thing you did and
have multiple charges in my campaign
Finance case they were like we'll get
you on bank fraud because you took your
money out of the bank we'll get you on
mail fraud because you put your check in
the mail and see those things carry
years in prison and so then they go okay
but if you sign here and plead to this
and so whether you're guilty or innocent
makes no difference if you make a
rational calculation you have to take
the plea but of course politically it's
ruinous because then everybody jumps up
and goes see he admitted it he so let me
let me let me give you an example I was
at a criminal trial a long time ago this
is another lifetime and the the federal
prosecutors said of the defendant who
quite literally broke no law but they
were trying to put him in prison for
decades I was flabbergasted when I heard
the prosecutor say they were it was
sentencing hearing why they wanted to
justify very very long prison sentence
and the prosecutor said your honor the
defendant used a uniform resource
locator through the hypertext transfer
protocol to obtain private information
of people he did not have the right to
get information from and I was like oh
my God he just said the dude typed in a
a URL into a web browser but he said it
in such a way
so that the jury and the judge would be
like wow what is this crazy technical
thing for which I am uh not
understanding if I said your honor the
dude typed some words into the browser
bar and pressed enter and they sent him
information he'd be like well I do that
every day right but they're trying to
justify putting him in prison for a
decade plus so that's why they use that
language I mean uh after this being a
police state film people come up to me
and they're like well you know Dena I'm
not Donald Trump and I didn't go in the
capital on January 6th and I pay my
taxes and you know I'm okay they're not
going to come after me and I say to
these guys I go listen why don't you
tell me for 10 minutes about your life
what do you do tell me where you live
tell me how you get to work you know
you're a doctor and I say after you
after 10 minutes I will tell you three
felonies that you can be charged with
that you will be defenseless against so
for example you're a doctor okay I'm
going to charge you with illegal
administration of pain medication I will
find one client that you admin a pain
drug to who says I didn't need it right
and I will then bring in an expert
witness a doctor who will testify she
really didn't need it you'll be facing
years in prison you'll be facing not
being able to be a doctor ever again or
you take a plea bargain you pay a
$100,000 fine you don't practice for a
year and then you can get back into it
well who wouldn't take that deal you
know that they got you it's blackmail
and it's it's blackmail and you're being
framed well it's called It's called The
Jury tax and it's some people call the
trial tax or the jury tax and and the
argument they make is well you see when
you plead guilty you're you're accepting
responsibility which shows some remorse
and some change already therefore you'll
get a lesser sentence for that the
reality is the emergence of this is
mostly due to the fact the state cannot
handle the amount of cases laid before
it if every person in this country who
was criminally charged demanded a jury
trial the system would would collapse
overnight well I just want to mention
because we spoke to him on the show
probably about two years ago but Brandon
straa had a very similar situation he
did not the he was just out the claimed
that they heard his the that he filmed
saying something that wasn't even
necessarily incendiary even in of itself
and they were threatening him with
something like 19 years in prison and so
they got him to plea down basically this
is what I remember about covering the
proud boys trial right they were all
charged with conspiracy but also if you
look back in the documents Dominic Piza
who had thrown some or there a video of
him like taking glass out of a window he
just
broke it yeah um the he got moved onto
the caseway later they moved people
around based on who they could offer
pleas to create this idea that there was
a
uniform that's what was so amazing about
the Whitmer Federal criminal trial and I
know you guys had Brandon certa on and
um the fact that you had and the thing
with plea deals too is they are
considered convictions by the Department
of Justice there's not a category that's
like and this is true I just it up % of
federal criminal cases charges end up
are are pleaded out but they're still
listed as a conviction so what was so
amazing with the Whitmer fedna trial is
that you had two of the six Federal
defendants who pleaded guilty and then
they became government Witnesses but
then you had four defendants who took
the risk they went to trial in a
jurisdiction really a jury of their
peers which they had and you had two men
Daniel Harris and Brandon Serta who were
here who were acquitted outright on
every single charge and then the other
two men who had a hung jury and of
course then the doj went back but that's
why it's so that case in in and of
itself is just amazing what happened let
me pull up this story real quick so we
can carry on this conversation this is a
story from the post-millennial Atlanta
antifa militants claim to have torched
concrete company trucks in effort to
stop cop City this is an ongoing Terror
campaign currently taking place in
Atlanta there have been 61 indictments
but guess what as Julie pointed out as
we're starting the show these are state
level and not federal level so antifa is
actively engaged these are people who
are part of cells these are people who
have come from outside the country we
know this and they have cells all over
the country they they work with each
other they organize they have plans they
have workbooks and we are told
consistently the far R is the real
threat I want to add something in the
previous segment we were talking about
the jury tax or the trial tax where they
force people to take ple plea uh plea
bargains dases was pointing out that he
can get you you tell me about your life
and he can point out three felonies I
want to tell you guys something and then
I want to open the conversation up to
January 6 and your in your film the uh
police date on January 20th 2017 several
hundred far- leftists stormed through
Washington DC throwing uh Molotov
cocktails uh uh well I I should I should
tone it down a little bit setting fires
in the street torching vehicles smashing
windows and fighting with cops several
hundred got arrested I know I was one of
those people who got arrested I was
released after I asked a supervisor and
I showed him my press pass he told me
too bad you're under arrest you're not
free to go and then eventually a
supervisor ordered the release of
journalists of which I was then
unarrested de arrested by the police I
was never processed this group was uh
all of these people were charged and
guess what not only did most of them
have the charges dropped the city paid
them millions of dollars and it was for
one reason they all refused to take a
plea deal the the state was struggling
or I shouldn't say the state the federal
government these are the feds they
almost never lose cases but they could
not get any of these individuals why
antifa wear all black for a reason it
doesn't matter if a cop actually sees
you a cop could see you you could take
your mask off you could smile and you
can wave and when it comes to the
criminal trial the defense will say what
was a defendant wearing and'll say a
black hoodie a black bandan a black
jeans with black gloves and you say
looked at you and smiled that's right
could you have been mistaken I mean
there were 300 people wearing the exact
same thing and the cop will say no it
was him and they look at the journal
like do you believe that that he
actually knew who this guy was with
everyone wearing the same thing they
couldn't get him on conspiracy charges
and they couldn't get anyone to believe
that they singled out individuals with
crimes so the entire group in their
organized Act of terrorism at Donald
Trump's inauguration were not only
having their charges dismissed but they
were paid out millions of dollars mhm
and let not forget the
529 absolutely when they broke down the
barriers outside of the White House and
forced the president of the United
States into a bunker instead of bomb the
White House grounds that's right and the
media's concern about that was that
Trump was very mean and he used tear gas
so that he could get across the street
and stop them from burning down a
historic church if they just like denes
was saying earlier they just by talking
to someone you can come up with you know
multiple felonies if the federal
government actually wanted to stop this
kind of stuff they absolutely could I
think this is the key that that you know
for years now we have focused on the
rhetoric of the double standard yeah
live in the logic look at the way look
at the way that the government treats
Trump versus Biden look at the treatment
of antifa versus antifa BLM on the one
hand versus let's say the January 6
protesters on the other now how do you
resolve a double standard because a
double standard usually has a kind of a
hidden premise and the hidden premise
here is that we have a government that
wants to apply the law
equitably and if that is the case then
there certainly is a double standard
they're not doing that but let's remove
that assumption let's assume that you're
dealing with an emerging police state
and now it's a police state but it's
we're not North Korea right if we were
North Korea or China I couldn't make a
movie called police state so we have to
be a police state in the making under
construction if you will and if a police
state is under construction it needs
political allies it needs it would
ideally like to have a whole political
party that is in bed with the police
state that's going to help build it and
so the police state is going to say the
police state now becomes like the family
dog notice how the family dog is really
friendly to members of the family and
Barks at strangers so the family dog is
not a hypocrite the family dog can
distinguish between the pals and
strangers and similarly the police state
is friendly toward the people who are
helping to build the police state even
as it is unly hostile to anybody that it
sees as a threat to the police state and
if you apply the single standard it all
makes sense you don't have a double
standard anymore they're acting
consistently it's a hierarchy that's
absolutely right well you can also
recognize them as the the militant arm
of the the party that's in power
basically and we've seen this
historically Communists have always done
this the Communist did this in Spain
where people who are non-government
officials or weren't necessarily
commissioned to by the government were
going and digging up the dead bodies of
nuns and Priests and displaying them in
churches in order to persecute
Christians and the government just
wouldn't arrest them when they did it
cuz of course they were perfectly happy
to see them do that and that was the
fact of the matter and that's what we
have in the United States today anti-
fund BLM run around burning down
buildings destroying people's lives
doing violence against innocent people
and even though they aren't technically
owned or told to do this by the
Democratic party or the political
establishment it allows them to so it's
just the same when people share an
ideology they don't need direct orders
from uh top down Authority if they all
are looking for the essentially the same
result which is to delegitimize the the
fundamental principles that the United
States are has built on if they're
looking for that result all the all the
tactics that they come up with they're
all acceptable Tim's Tim's talking about
uh shared what is it a diversity of te
talked about that a bunch of times when
you go to a left left liberal protest
where there's thousands of people you
will see what they they look man these
people lie because in their
worldview lying to accomplish your goal
is fine the ends justify the means and
what you end up with is a wide range
from Liberal to far-left extremist
tankes and they all say the same thing
respect the diversity of tactics and I
would ask them what that means and they
would say well not everybody agrees
there's one way to to bring about change
so if someone in that we we may not
completely agree with how they're doing
things but we're mostly lined
politically we just back off and let
them do their thing I want to point
something out right now uh October 7th
the attack in in uh Israel that was a
diversity of tactics that's the same
exact thing and that's why you see the
left in New York City people saying
they're Freedom Fighters decolonized
This is what people should should pay
attention to not every single person who
is in support of Palestine is in support
of Hamas Fair Point not every single
person who was marching knows exactly
what they're what they're protesting but
they're all told the same thing by the
organizers to
uh to respect the diversity of tactics
is the phrase they use now think about
what that means when a guy stands up
with a megaphone and celebrates 5,000
rocket attacks exploding over Tel Aviv
or hitting uh uh some of these hospitals
or whatever when they cheer for their
resistance Fighters these other liberals
who aren't really don't really know a
lot are told but you have to respect it
and so they may not 100% align but they
don't interfere as these people advocate
for these things here's the important
takeaway you may not care about Israel
palese where the United States I think
domestic issues are way more important
totally fair but when you have people
marching alongside pramas extremists and
these people don't care about Hamas but
they're holding up decolonized signs and
clapping for the Freedom Fighters
understand what their mentality is here
in the United States they would do
exactly as Hamas did here to accomplish
their goals 100% to the point where
Hassan on his show said but the
but some of those babies are settlers in
reference to the justification of
killing settlers referencing that babies
are also settlers I'd like to give them
the benefit of the doubt I'd like to but
I think it's very dangerous when a dude
has consistently been in support of like
well look when Assan literally says that
Hamas is just morally and legally in the
right to to do these things to reclaim
stolen land and then ads and babies are
settlers I just don't see I I don't see
why we should give him the benefit of
the
death um we we also you know this is
such an awkward topic because until you
have a firsthand experience it is
difficult to believe now Julie for
example you've sat in on so many trials
right and and we've talked a little bit
about this I mean you you almost feel
like you're living in a surreal America
because you're seeing it and yet it is a
knowledge that is a little
incommunicable uh for me like a turning
point in my whole career was you know if
you would ask me 10 years ago or 15
years ago like what's American politics
in a nutshell I would go well it's like
a debating Society you've got the left
you got the right you have two different
Visions these people value Liberty these
people value equality uh Liberty
equality of of Rights equality of
outcomes and you put these rival Visions
before the American people and the
people choose and sometimes they go this
side sometimes they go that side and
then when I was sitting across from the
lawyers of the Obama doj and I realized
in this conversation I'm having with
these guys that for a trivial offense if
they could have locked me up for 10
years they would have done done it and I
realized W well that's a wrecking ball
in my whole theory of American po or
even all the guys I knew you know I
lived in DC so it's a small town I knew
EJ Dion at the Washington Post I knew
guys at all the different you know
liberal outlets and I saw these guys in
Trover bookstore I saw them in
restaurants when my case came up they
come up to me they be dases man looks
like you're really being shafted and I'd
be like okay EJ well if I'm being
shafted you know Megan Kelly's saying
that on Fox news but it'd be really
helpful you said that in the Washington
Post because for a liberal to defend me
against Obama H I got that kind of
awkward I can't really do that yeah and
then you realize again that this is not
quite the America you thought you were
living in it's become gangster no
America politics is America's most
extreme and crazy team sport you have to
be loyal to your side no matter what and
I think that's true on both sides it's
really easy to see where the left locks
down in some ways they're more effective
right they're able to get a lot of young
people to go out and do their bidding by
saying these trigger words and saying
colonizer and then they all know exactly
what side they're against but I also
think that the right does this too where
there are some uh portions of the party
where they say I'm not I'm too afraid to
say anything I mean that was what I
found really interesting about the
freedom caucus right they like all of
these people started saying these are
our values we have American first values
we want to push forward and in and they
gain traction even though the mainstream
RNC was not super comfortable with it
well you know they're being defeated and
it feels pretty good so hearing Kevin
McCarthy elbowed uh brette in the back
I'm like man he's losing it but so be it
the stories that I've heard about the
things the established Republicans have
done to uh good Americans who wanted to
serve this country and sometimes serve
it again this time as as public officers
uh good riddance good riddance to the to
to this extremism and tribalism uh you
know I I'll Circle back a little bit of
the daily wire here because it thought
just occurred to me that with regard to
the Candace business and that is that
daily wire has been out of sync with
Trump right they've been kind of part of
the never Trump or camp and so on and
and they're very successful company but
it's a little tricky for them as a brand
you're a very successful company but
you're out of sync with the mainstream
of the Republican party so daily wire
needs some Maga Spirit uh if only to
deflect the never trumpism that's
clearly in in Daily wire so so Candice
actually has a lot of because she
represents that she comes in from that
kind of magga wing if you will and then
Dy W can say as Jeremy boring has said
you know we are open to all different
points of view and so on so and they can
ask themselves why is her audience loyal
to her I mean it makes them potentially
expand their business model of course
exactly that's my point is that the
daily wire there's always a little bit
of a danger that they go the way of the
National Review yes the National Review
dug in on anti-trump on never Trump
would not back off and pushed out Victor
Davis Hansen who was basically the one
crime one Trump guy but and a historian
who knows more than all of them but good
mind he's brilliant he's great a lot of
people right now are very critical of
the daily wire especially in our chat
but I hope this is worth at least
something uh man when I sit down with
big corporate media companies and
lawyers and I've rejected all of them it
is the most annoying and insulting thing
I've had companies send me contracts
where they're like here's the deal here
we want to do I'm like this sounds great
we shake hands they sent me a contract
totally the opposite that steals
everything and is destructive and the
response is well hire a lawyer and
Redline it and when I sat down with
Jeremy it was like it was like talking
it was legit and and I really do respect
that I feel bad for him with all this
going on I hope at the end of it there's
no bad blood canace and Ben get along I
hope this resolves itself generates some
press for him it's not just about you
know I know I know them and I don't like
it when people fight but it really is
also about if if we are all in agreement
on 90% of things then come on man if if
the far-left can all wear the same
clothes and get away with committing
crimes we're not even anywhere like
trying to advocate for anything close to
that we're just saying guys let's let's
focus on the issues that we need to
focus on and stop tearing each other
down well we want to build a parallel
economy and and to do that and and and
we're in a hard business because people
block you you know you can't advertise
on YouTube and you can't put your ads up
on Facebook and then Walmart won't sell
your DVDs so if you can build a
successful company in with that wind
against you you're doing something right
so that's yeah and I think there are I
mean no matter what happens right now
with the daily wire they have done a lot
of really positive things oh I think we
just lost your mic did you I touched my
wire one time uh I said that the daily
wire has done positive things we don't
need a monolith of every single news
organization or you know alternative
Media Company saying exactly the same
thing but they themselves have to
tolerate a little bit of diversity of
thought
absolutely can I I I just want to touch
on one thing uh with des's political
prosecution and I firmly believe that's
what it was I've said that before i'
I've done videos on it discussing it
let's let's let's can we get like
elevator pitch as to what that was just
so for the people who aren't super
familiar with the details sure a a
college friend of mine Wendy long
decided to run for the Senate I begged
her not to I told her that she was you
know would be would lose terribly but
she goes I want to do it so I go okay
I'll help you I gave her $10,000 which
is the campaign Finance limit but what
was happening is i' put out a new film
on Obama I was traveling all over the
country and you know how it is with with
a friend of yours she's like oh denes
you know can you come and meet these
Indian doctors I mean they're Indian
you're Indian you know we want to raise
some money here I'm like oh Wendy I'm in
Dallas you know so I felt bad so I told
two of my friends listen do you like
Wendy long give her $10,000 I'll
reimburse you so this is this was my
crime I exceeded the campaign Finance
law and look I did right so I should get
the same penalty as anybody else who did
that but normally that penalty is
nothing or at the most it's community
service so warning especially if it's a
first time offense the key to the
campaign Finance law is you're not doing
a quit pro quo like hey I'll give you
money but I want you to make me a judge
then you're getting something corrupt
out of the deal this was not the case
here not even charged so that's was what
my case was about and the US government
would have liked to have locked me up
for more than as long as they could but
two years was the sort of statutory
maximum so they were going for it they
had a Clinton appointed judge I mean the
whole thing was like a show trial made
you get reeducate bman in New York oh in
New York it was sdny the southern
district of New York so wow so it was it
was Eric Holder but operating through an
Indian stooge whom I nicknamed Indian
Head waiter prit barara a guy who's uh
had a lot of notorious cases wow and so
on top of all this right so this is a
crime that as you mentioned people
normally will get community service for
or it's not prosecuted and not only do
they send you to prison community
service I'm sorry they have you do
re-education basically re-education a
big fine I mean when I told people I had
5 years probation there were guys in
prison who were like coyotes drug
smugglers I mean people who had in for
rape and they were like I got two years
you know they couldn't believe it and
they and I had great difficulty you know
one of the key things about prison is
like what are you in for and part of the
problem was I felt like I might like
make all these enemies because none of
them believed what I would say they're
like whose money did you take I'm like
no no no I didn't take anybody's money I
gave too much of my own money they're
like this guy's lying can't trust him
what did you how many how much time did
you end up so I was I was 8 months in an
overnight confinement Center so I was
free in the day but I checked in at 7:00
at night and I would check out at 7:00
in the morning and I slept in a dorm
with 70 Hardon criminals on a bunk bed
did you make friends uh I made some
acquaintances uh perhaps not friends um
but you know it's a window into our
Criminal Justice System it's a unique
experience for it's a very unique
experience although maybe not really a
lot of people are incarcerated yeah yeah
sorry I interrupted you Sheamus did you
yeah well no I just want to mention this
cuz what you said is it would have
helped you if people on the left would
have stood up for you when you were the
victim of an obvious political
prosecution what's very sad today is
when people on the right are victims of
political prosecution people on the
right won't even stand up for them
gotten to that point prior to your your
case who was the who was politically
prosecuted before you I feel like you're
the first kind of high-profile one at
least since the turn of the century or
it was it was the first case but
interestingly at the time I saw it as a
one-off I mean I did not see it as a
Prelude to Carter page Papadopoulos
Roger Stone Michael Flynn Trump because
the way I saw it was okay uh I made a
movie on Obama it was emotionally
damaging because I went to the Obama
family Homestead I interviewed his
brother I kind of I made it kind of
personal and I'm like I know this guy's
a vindictive narcissist so it I should
have known there's going to be a big
Target on my back but I didn't see the
the institutional creep that that has
occurred the escalation under Biden of
the police state has taken me by
surprise do you feel like you were sort
of a test case they were seeing how they
could test the law and apply it in this
kind of scenario yeah you know I thought
my case was a oneoff where Obama I mean
and this is funny because I go speak on
campuses right and people would be like
I'd be like I was targeted and then
people go what makes you think Obama
watch your stupid movie and I go I go
well the movie was in 200000 theaters
and and when the movie was reached the
second most successful political film
ever made I was being attacked every day
on a website called Barack obama.com so
that's kind of where I got the wacky
idea that maybe Obama didn't like my
film EXA even if somebody makes a a a
film someone makes a documentary expose
you explaining all the things wrong with
you you don't have to see the movie to
not like the person like it's not like
Obama would have to sit down and be like
I disagree uh with this film likees that
was people around him were like he said
this and he showed your family in this
light and that's all that's all you need
Obama went after the Tea
Party the started unjustly auditing them
and then we also know that Barack Obama
charged more people uh uh whistleblowers
and journalists under the Espionage Act
than all other presidents combined they
call him Obama I I believe that Barack
Obama may be one of the worst Presidents
one of uh uh in my lifetime I think he's
the worst and a lot of people yeah oh
yeah yeah Joe Joe Joe may be heavily
influenced or or uh uh puppeted by Obama
but let me say this I know it's it's
it's kind of tough because you got you
got W bush you got Iraq you got
Afghanistan they just horrible things
and you have uh like Bush's attempt at
Presidential Directive 51 if you guys
are familiar with that but Barack Obama
has a I don't know like the National
Defense authorization authorization act
indefinite detention Provisions the
persecution of journalists the kill the
extrajudicial assassinations of American
citizens uh we have what he did to you
we have what he did to the uh uh um to
the tea party and you know honestly the
list goes on well bombing civilian
hurricane Crossfire hurricane how about
Fast and Furious knew all about it fast
and furious sending guns to cartels this
is the most protected man in American
history and uh part of it was the first
black president that gave him an
immediate sort of uh Halo and um and
he's also one of the most ruthless so um
I think he's still around yeah and and
now he he he reflects a tendency that's
broad on the left because you can tell
whenever you're looking at stuff that
the leftist D they know that they are
above the law when Jamal Bowman pulled
the fire extinguisher he removed the
signs I bet it never crossed his mind
I'm going to be arrested I'm going to be
locked up it's going I'm going to be
held for three months he was probably
insulted when he got arrested he should
you know who I am yeah or or or look at
those those protesters what was it in
which building was it the Canon building
I didn't see the slightest fear in their
eyes that they're going to come in here
drag us to the floor put us in solitary
they knew it was never going to happen
do you think Barack Obama is a leftist
or do you think he's a bad
liberal no I think that I think that
this is a guy and I've done a lot of
work on on on Obama I think this is a
guy who is is haunted by anti-colonial
demons uh that came from his father and
his father was a very intoxicating well
he was intoxicated he was drunk but he
was a he was also a very captivating
personality um a a complete con artist
uh in Kenya for example he would
frequently show up at public events
pretending to be a minister of this a
minister of finance he'd be up on the
podium giving a speech when the real
Minister of Finance would walk in the
door I mean there's a comic aspect have
him arrested he's he's faking it I see
that in in Obama's brother I see that in
and Obama and he abandoned Obama at
Birth basically and and and
paradoxically Obama was obsessed with
the father he never had had he goes down
to Kenya he goes to his father's grave
he has this kind of voodoo experience at
the grave it's all in my film by the way
2016 Obama's America um Obama's a very
interesting guy and I think part of what
put me on to him was I had been seeing
him through a civil rights lens you know
this is a guy his background is like
Montgomery Selma Martin Luther King and
that's how he was being portrayed yeah
and then when I read his autobiography
dreams from my father I was like oh wow
this is really more like the India I
grew up in all the Indian intellectuals
talking about anti-colonialism and the
British I'm like this is the soil in
which this guy was cultivated so you
think he's a leftist then he is he is a
leftist in this you know we're talking
about Hamas
decolonization Israel is the colonial
power little babies are settlers that's
Obama's ideology he's a smart guy he's a
smart guy you you can't underestimate I
mean the degree to which he has been
influential authoritarian the
authoritarian grasp and the things that
he's been able to do are shocking the
ability well you have you have Lisa
Monaco who was a longtime loyalist of
his his his last Homeland Security
adviser was Chief of Staff to Robert
Mueller and where is she now she's the
deputy attorney general you have ail
Haynes who also was a top Deputy for
Barack Obama and she is now Joe Biden's
Director of National Intelligence and of
course then you had Susan Rice uh who
was the domestic policy adviser for a
long time so he he and he is the only
President who has remained in Washington
DC and now we know from reporting that
you have Biden administrated
Administration officials and Democrats
going to their mansion in Karama and
meeting with him so he still is highly
influential uh in this Administration
and think overall if Obama decided it is
important to me to move Biden out yeah
and kamla Harris out don't you think
that this would then become a top
priority for the Democratic party but do
you think that's why Biden is running
again because Obama ultimately wants him
to stay in office so he continue have
control well I because I don't think the
DNC wants Biden at all so we we have
this line I think it's one of the best
lines in police state where and it's
Darren be's talking and he says he goes
in a police state he goes you normally
know who's running it right who's
running China X who was running Cuba
Castro who was running the old Soviet
Union Stalin mhm but our police state
says Darren is is a little opaque Biden
is in the canoe he's obviously a willing
accomplice but who's steering the canoe
we don't know I mean this is a country
right now being run in my view by some
kind of a hunter yeah there are powerful
people who are making decisions Biden is
cooperating with them Obama may or may
not be directing them but I think it's
the Obama ites it's the Obama gang
that's running it and in a way Biden's
very convenient CU I mean think about it
you bring in you you know you bring in
some strong willed guy from California
Gavin Nome he's going to want to run the
show he's going to want to give orders
he's got a future ahead of him he's got
a future they Biden can't be the
candidate he can't be the nominee I mean
there's this really great clip we have
from a Joe Rogan Experience with the
rock where The Rock Says look I got
friends who support Trump I got friends
who support Biden and then Joe goes you
actually have friends that support Joe
Biden and he goes no no no no no no no
good good check he's like that's that
context matters I friends who support
the Democrats the reason that he they
can't have him though is because of the
hit because of the the gaffs that he's
likely to do that are going to likely
get worse not because they not because
they he won't listen or just it's it's
because here's what I wonder that the
reason why they wanted Biden to be the
candidate in 2020 was because they
needed a sacrificial lamb whoever they
put in place had to reverse policies
Trump did that worked and made us feel
good and that's going to cause a lot of
hurt whoever does that is going to
suffer in the polls and in favorability
so we need someone who's not going to
run again all we need is your corporeal
for uh form Joe Biden that's what the
article said remember that one from the
Atlantic stay alive Joe Biden all we
need is your corporeal form I think
you're right but I still think that the
risk of having Joe Biden run again is
because of how because a failure on his
part a mistake an error shows that he's
not the guy running well that's what I
was about to mention denes you made this
point about the US almost being the Str
kind of puppet state where we don't
actually know who's in control behind
the scenes and this is something people
always speculated might be the case but
then when Joe Biden came along just
became obvious that at least in this
Administration that definitely has to be
the case there's no way this guy's
making decisions he does not know he's
the president I'm sure he forgets half
the time more than half the time man's
completely out of it I mean he's he's in
steep cognitive decline it was pretty
clear that there were times when Donald
Trump would try to get something done
and the the you know the bureaucracy
itself would be work working against him
and they ad it and they admitted it and
I think with with Joe Biden it is clear
that whether or not Joe Biden says the
right thing the bureaucracy already
knows what's going to happen I mean he
said it himself they'll get in they'll
get mad at me if I say that what do they
want me to do he he speaks like that
regularly Julie what do you think about
the Biden's chances in 2024 I don't I
don't think he's going anywhere and uh
if he wanted to there's no way that Dr
Jill will uh let him leave the white
house because she wants to stay first
lady more than I think she wants he
wants to be president you think that she
no way do you know
about and her her her you know
imaginations of towards power or
whatever what do you know she wants to
be first lady she wants to stay first
lady she wants to insulate that family
which they are to a degree obviously
they are because they're still in the
white house uh I I don't see any way to
get him out of there he's not going to
leave
voluntarily uh unless you know he dies
look at the way that the Democrats with
a straight face and there's got to be a
little part of them that's a little
sheepish in saying this kind of stuff
but I mean recently you saw in MSNBC
someone goes well Biden's more
articulate than any functioning
45-year-old right I mean for some for
45y old for someone to say that with a
straight face uh so with with with
Democrats they can count and Federman
the same they can count on a level of of
media
rationalization media protection that is
just that will go to insane levels to
defend these people and I think they
have gone out of the way to present
themselves as like the best family they
could partially because they have so
much baggage looking at you Hunter uh I
me I mean they look back at Naomi
Biden's wedding that got her spread in
Vogue and the first picture you see is
her and you know her grandmother Jill
cuddled on the couch they are trying to
say we are this like ultimate American
family and we are restoring the White
House to this nice place and or I mean
but I mean look at the intellectual Ju
jits where you got a family Racket and
then they come out and go well I mean
this shows you that this man has just an
absolutely immeasurable love for his kid
and even when
right this this Vogue shoot that I'm
referencing it's interesting because it
was like right before Tiffany Trump
wedding at marago but also Hunters
nowhere to be seen in it right the the
bidens are basically trying to pass
themselves off as this nice set of
grandparents skip a generation and then
they've got all these granddaughters
forget the grandsons you know what I
mean like it's a weird family and they
ultimately do these things to be
palatable to the American people to seem
glamorous and desirable and to stay in
the white house so do you think uh Jill
and Joe have kind of like a bill Hillary
thing going on here where she's actually
pulling the strings and he's just the
the face of the organization cuz he's
honestly not a very good face right like
Bill Clinton has many flaws but he had
some Charisma so I could understand why
someone like her would attach herself to
him in order he was Maxim charismatic in
the still horrible back then a horrible
man but but he was in charge Wasing
charge right Joe Joe sniffs children con
Biden was very Charming I mean that's
how he got where he was for oh that's
where he got where he is he always
seemed like a phony and a blow heart
even when I watch old CS of him he seems
like
a never struck as Charming he didn't
yeah in his younger days he had a he had
a frat boy quality by the way similar to
Clinton uh I think in the Clinton case
Hillary
was sufficiently self-aware to realize
that she could not make it across the
Finish Line without bill so I think she
signed up with Bill early on she
understood that this was a a bargain
because it was going to come with a lot
of baggage bill was going to do his own
thing but fillary was like that's okay
because I've got my eye on Power and in
the end if I become kind of Bill's
coverup man there are similar uh
conversations had about Jackie Kennedy
and JFK that she was aware of some of
his you know less desirable qualities
specifically philandering and that she
chose chose anyways not to see political
office but generally to seek social
capital and power interesting yes I want
to jump to this story we have this tweet
that uh Phil had actually retweeted from
yasher Ali he tweets over the past 24
hours thousands of Tik toks at least
have been posted where people share how
they just read Bin Laden's Infamous
letter to America in which he explained
why he attacked the United States the
Tik toks are from people of all ages
races ethnic ities and backgrounds many
of them say that reading the letter has
opened their eyes and they'll never see
geopolitical matters the same way again
many of them and I've watched a lot say
it has made them reevaluate their
perspective on how what is often labeled
as terrorism can be a legitimate form of
resistance to a hostile power this is
not limited to Tik Tok similar videos
have been posted on other social media
platforms the guardian had a copy of
letter to America posted but once these
Tik toks went viral the guardian took it
down which has only led to more interest
in the letter and conspiracies from Tik
Tok ERS who say this is part of the
media and the powers that control it
trying to silence the truth and my takea
away from this my personal perspective
Tik Tok wants to foster a pro Hamas Pro
Terror anti anti-west decolonize this is
why I have been in favor of banning Tik
Tock yeah I I don't care sorry the Free
Speech the first all that that applies
to the United States and if foreign
entities are attacking us and trying to
subvert the country then we do something
about it maybe Banning isn't the answer
but something must be done and you get
these Republicans who are like they're
spying on our data and I'm like oh I
don't care about that I care about Tik
Tok promoting thousands of letters to
America Bin Laden perspectives on 911 to
young people the the the the important
thing about Tik Tock isn't that they're
get that that China may be collecting
data it's that people are are being fed
information and they're I mean the like
button is is such a massive massive
influence on people if they if they make
manipulated we know that the their
equivalent app feeds very different
things to their young people than it
does to American young people that is a
huge amount of influence and control to
give over we talk about the fact you
should send your kids to public schools
because you're giving their teachers
like a sort of unfettered chance to
shape their brains but you buy them a
smartphone and let them get on Tik Tok
and if kids are getting this kind of uh
this kind of stuff fed to them all the
time in conjunction with not getting a
Civics education about how our
government works why things are the way
they are if you tell a kid that we're a
democracy from they from when they're 5
years old until they're 18 years old and
they think we're a democracy and then
there's a president that is elected and
doesn't get the the the the majority
vote they're going to think oh this is
terrible if they understood how our
system works they wouldn't have this
massive negative reaction to it they'd
be like well it works this way and I
understand why the ignorance that people
have about our own government our own
fundamental principles that our that our
country is founded on and how our
government works is probably the worst
thing that is going on in the politics
today is the ignorance people have about
the way that our system works M yeah are
there are there riots going on right now
at the DNC mhm yeah oh man well how
about that the DNC here guys want to
take a is there a pipe bomb there was
that
theom no I don't know I'm just seeing
videos it's not far at all yeah we're
like right there liby emons post a video
of of they're fighting cops they're
trying to break into the building that's
happening right now it's happening right
take IRL live on the street to the DNC
should I go the pick up your microphone
your own camera don't grab your wire I
can't I'm yeah I'm seeing I'm seeing
these tweets and uh this is uh wow this
is this is absolutely insane Greg price
tweets this currently happening outside
the DNC headquarters in Washington
far-left Pro Palestine riers are
clashing with police trying to into the
building it's really funny that I I'm
pulling this up in the middle of our our
young people are being manipulated into
supporting Terror you know literally
acting out I'll a couple thoughts about
this because it actually flashes my mind
to um right after 911 U as you know TV
went off the air and then the next
Monday was the first time we was back on
and I was on with Bill Maher I was on um
Bill Mah show Politically Incorrect you
already been scheduled to be there I've
been scheduled to be there a but
interestingly like a couple blocks away
yeah interestingly uh another guest was
who was the name of the woman who died
in 911 uh the wife of Barbara ol bar ol
was Barbara Olson was scheduled to be on
with us so glad when I remember and so
we had this Bill Mar session with an
empty chair you know but the reason I
mentioned this is that the conversation
led to Bill Mah getting fired from the
show and Bill Mah asked me in that show
he goes asking about the terrorists he
goes would you say that the 9/11
terrorists were
cowards and I said in my opinion no uh I
said it's not I said it takes something
to be able to fly a plane into a
building just like if you tell me to get
my car right now and drive into a a
concrete structure I'm going to be a
little reluctant to do that and then
bill marah went on to say well I think
our military are the real cowards
because we sit 4,000 miles away and
press a button and kill people in other
countries and that got all the veterans
against him and so on and he you know
that's how he got the boot the reason I
mentioned all this is because in the
background was Bin Laden's letter to
America because Bin Laden makes one
point and I bet you this is what's
getting all these Tik Tok people riled
up basically what Bin Laden says is that
in a democracy there are no civilians he
says he says we did 911 yes and he goes
but that's because the American people
democratically voted for the governments
that have these policies and so you're
asking me Bin Laden says to distinguish
between military and civilian targets
but what if the civilians are the ones
who are putting the elected leaders who
have these policies in power they're
consing to their military yes they are
basically themselves part of the problem
I I got a I got a video right here sorry
I'm just watching these break Clips
where this woman says our own party is
is attacking peaceful protesters and etc
etc I I can't see how Democrats are
going to be able to win next year the
the Democrats that think that the
protesters are in their party are having
a wakeup call and this is something that
I've been that I've mentioned on the
show a lot there is a difference and
it's what it it relates to why I asked
you about Barack Obama there is a
difference between leftists and
Democrats Democrats are liberals that
are doing bad things because leftists
have tricked them yes but so uh what did
we see in 2020 we saw prominent leftist
YouTubers and personality say vote Biden
and now what we're seeing with with this
wave okay a year is an eternity in
politics so maybe by next November this
stuff doesn't even play as big a role as
we thought however what percentage uh
you you guys might know this D you might
know this what percentage of the vote
comes from uh uh the 18 to 24 uh voting
Block it's it's low I know it's
relatively low yeah I don't know the
percentage but it's not it's not
significant enough to to to carry
3% I'm going look up maybe a little more
let's look it up yeah more if the
Democrats lost let's say that's how they
won in 2022 college campuses that's how
they won let's say it's 5% MH if they
lost half that I don't see how they they
they could drop 2.5 points over the
Palestine stuff but I think it'll be
more substantial I think what we're
going to end up seeing now with these
viral videos you're going to see
subversive right-wing accounts targeting
the left by replaying Clips like this of
Democrats attacking Pro Palestine
protesters in an effort to fracture the
youth vote for Democrats interesting
question I mean the Democrats have three
ways to go right they can go with the
with the Palestinian with the Palestine
resistors that's one way to go the
second way is to go the opposite
direction and basically the way Biden
started out I'm for Israel
and the third way is to try to
accommodate both I they can't do both
they can't do both and and they will not
sacrifice APAC and the Jewish community
no they're going to go the way that that
the the soccer moms will vote because
that's who really kind of wins for the
Democrats regardless of of of like when
when soccer moms voted for Trump and
they vot voted Republican the Democrats
lost because of it your average soccer
mom that is a Suburban mother that has
kids in school that's the core of the
Democrat Party and they influence not
just them it's not just them but they
influence the whole household so I think
they're still going to focus how do you
explain the enthusiasm of the Democrats
for not just the trans issue but all
kinds of extreme perversion that can't
possibly go down very well with soccer
moms I think that mostly it's leftists
that are pushing that stuff activists
but why why doesn't the Democratic party
go we want nothing to do with this
because they've been too afraid to
actually stand up and and take the heat
because you do have to take heat when
you stand up against what what amounts
to the LGBT Lobby it's not just you know
you're not just saying oh this is bad so
you you you you're you're taking the
fact that it is a mean quote unquote
perspective to say no we should have
limits on what kind of stuff can be our
children can be exposed to and then to
top it off you've got the fact that
there's a whole Lobby pushing against it
so look Suburban moms are going to vote
the way that the view tells them to vote
absolutely they're I mean they're not
paying close attention to the details of
this conflict I mean this is my this is
my crew trust me what the view says
whatever the symbols on Facebook are
it's the
viewer propaganda it's also I mean you
have to say Suburban moms are very
conscious of social Chic in other words
of being acceptable to your well the
whole the whole the whole Progressive
project in in the United States nowadays
the whole Progressive project is
essentially just like luxury beliefs
that's right you know these are all
first world problems that people are
having because our society is so
successful even now with like a A
downturn in the economy we're in
recession even though the government
doesn't want to want to admit it but
we're still a very successful Society a
very wealthy Society where we can have
luxury beliefs or or take time out to do
activism and stuff like that I just want
to say p research has um in 2018 11 or
yeah yeah 11% of 18 to 29 year olds were
voters in 2022 it was uh 10% of 18 to 29
year old so I'll find wait wa 10% of the
votes they received came from 18 to 29
year olds mhm yeah that's what she said
wow but you said 18 to 24 right so I'll
I'll try and find it that's just fascina
cut it in half you're probably right no
but I think 18 to 29 is the good that is
yeah that's the young demographic that's
more likely to be Pro uh Pro Palestine
as opposed to pro Israel the older you
get the more it shifts if they lose half
that what they lose 5% of their of their
votes they can't win that's a 2.5 swing
in the general Trump's already pulling
up now again a year as an eternity in
electoral and this is I I'll try and
find uh 2020 and uh 2016 because this is
obviously you know a midcycle
election Phil you mentioned this idea of
luxury beliefs I think that's a perfect
way of putting it that summarizes a lot
of the values of the democratic party
today and just left-wing individuals
generally speaking the idea that you
have time to get worked up over whether
someone's using your they them pronouns
when you're clearly a man or clearly
because all of your basic needs are so
readily met that you can meditate on all
the ways that you consider yourself to
be special and then be up in arms when
other people don't acknowledge that it's
a very real problem it's a very real
problem and one thing I've also noticed
is even when you're not talking about
people who have those specific values or
view themselves in that way I think once
people have their needs met and
particularly once they become wealthy
and the wealthier they become I have
found the more of an inordinate
unhealthy emphasis they place on their
reputation
and I think it gets worse often times
the more money people have it becomes
more of a Temptation I'm not saying it's
always the case it's just something I've
noticed generally speaking and so once
your country becomes very affluent I
think this stuff really starts to seep
in it's the the typical Good Times
create weak men scenario you want to say
something yeah that I think the the
other element of it is the um the
reemergence of a kind of aristocratic
sensibility so the aristocratic
sensibility is I'm riding my horse and
here's a peasant and he's saying
something annoying and my natural
attitude is shut up peasant you
shouldn't be able to speak right so that
is there's an authoritarianism there
which arises out of the idea that I am a
superior human being and an inferior
creature has DED to challenge me this is
like unacceptable on principle right so
I think that because think about it you
could if if it is true that we have
these luxury beliefs you don't need a
police state you could let the
Republicans do what they want no reason
to shut them down no no reason to put
Desh in prison no no reason because you
you got the media you got education you
got Hollywood you've got all the big
megaphones of the culture you should be
able to beat Trump but yet they're like
The Peasants yep The Peasants are not
listening to us that's exctly got to
censor them I think that's exactly right
and last time I was on the show I I
mentioned something similar which is
that the reason they have to resort to
using the legal system is because people
no longer trust the media if they could
force their hegemony just by saying the
acceptable perspectives on television
and having people believe them they
would not have locked you up they would
not be threatening and pursuing legal
action against Donald Trump and the
people surrounding him they would just
assassinate their character in the media
but that doesn't work anymore because
nobody trusts the media and for good
reasons so now they actually have to
find these legal Solutions I just want
to say sorry the tus estimates that 50%
of 18 to 29y olds voted in 2020 and
that's up 11 points from 2016 when they
said 39% of 1829 so it's high it's much
higher during a presidential election
year I feel like that's worth noting
Julie do you think that um the what
Sheamus was saying it's it's when they
use the law do you think that reinforces
the message that they're trying to put
out because I feel like it's a
combination of what's what Sheamus is
saying because I do think that's real
but I think that the reason that they
went after UD why they're going after
January 6 is to kind of put an extra
stamp of validity to what essentially
amounts to to Bunk charges like most of
the stuff that people at January 6 are
charged with the vast majority of it is
garbage the vast majority of the
political prosecutions that we see you
know the the parents in Virginia that
were prosecuted the the the FBI looking
at people the IRS looking at
conservatives theas here obviously these
were all things that were essentially
fabricated so that the government could
use or so that the government could use
the force of government against the
private sector and so as you point out
the media would be enough but I feel
like the the use of the government is to
kind of put a stamp on it like we've
said this this is the message and if you
get out of line we will use the
government just to to repair your
opinion repair it yeah yeah I mean Obama
said at one point he said something like
you know we've got all these Outlets but
there's a whole group of Americans that
we can't reach and I think what he meant
is the Americans who are like on breit
bar listen to you know war room and Tim
Po and they read dena's books so I think
the goal if I think back to my case what
was their real goal it wasn't
incarceration the real goal was to was
to destroy my career to sort of disable
me and people don't want me to speak
Publishers don't want to publish my
books so I realized that early on and I
said to myself at the end of the day if
I can come out of it and my career is
bigger than it was before I went in then
I win mhm if if I basically become
somebody where I'm now begging to speak
and nobody wants me to speak then they
win and you know what the fact that you
have had success after this um is
something that at least theoretically
could have dissuaded them from trying
the same tactic in the future uh
unfortunately I don't think it it has as
much but if they were able to just
totally destroy your career I think they
would have done this way
more I you know I was talking to some I
actually talking to Bevin batty who was
in in police state and she made a very
valid point she goes denish you know you
hired a quarter of million dollar lawyer
you had Ben brafman one of the best
lawyers in New York City uh you had you
know you had Megan Kelly you had Ted
Cruz who went to Donald Trump and asked
Trump to pardon me so she goes you had
resources available to you that January
6 defendants and moms at Schoolboard
meetings and pro-life activists do not
have and I think we can see the ruthless
way in which some of those people's
lives have just been stamped down M and
it is a message so Phil to your point I
mean they are we ionizing statutes like
obstruction of an official proceeding
1512 C2 which was passed after the Enron
Scandal and it dealt with evidence
tampering well now it's been charged
against more than 300 January 6
defendants it's a felony count and it's
never been used in this way and you have
the DC appell at court who a slim
majority upheld the use of this 1512 C2
against 300 plus January Sixers it's one
of the counts in Jack Smith indictment
against Donald Trump but the
weaponization of that what they've done
is use that now to criminalize political
dissent so it it's moved away from its
original intent which everyone knows
what it was and now it can be used if
you disrupt a a you know proceeding in
Congress or any federal government
meeting it won't just be Congress it it
it will be everywhere and it will be
prosecuted selectively as well it's not
going to be well Jamal Bowman should
have been charged all of the all of the
protesters in the can an office building
the people who have disrupted the Senate
Foreign Affairs all of the Senate
hearings all the writers during 2020 the
single single biggest freak out I've
seen in the last several days was When
Donald Trump said in effect two can play
at this game right and he said so keep
it up guys but while you're winning but
Power changes hands we can do it to you
and the SC you know the the hysteria
over that Trump is admitting that he's
an authoritarian there are people going
to do what we're
doing to go after his political foes
there are people that are all that
already have campaign signs there's
someone from New Jersey that's running I
think he's a congress person in New
Jersey he was talking about how Donald
Trump is saying that he's going to make
an authoritarian blah blah blah and he's
got a tank in his his uh ad and stuff I
put it up on my Twitter account using
the underneath the picture of Joe Biden
when he had the red background and the
Marines behind him um because I wanted
to draw the contrast but there's already
people that are using that exact exact
talking point that you guys just pointed
out they're already using it it's
already in print yeah do you guys see
that uh widespread story raids and
concentration camps the guy in MSNBC
said Trump's telling us he's going to
build concentration
camps he really he said he said a clown
with a flamethrower still has a
flamethrower and so we're working on
that t-shirt right now it's a going be
Trump with flamethrower to the to the
swamp also again because Trump is
basically saying two can play at that
all they're doing is projecting here and
telling you what they would like to do
what they are doing yeah they're telling
you what they are doing now yeah there's
not there's not a it's not a threat
anymore it's clearly happening all
around us constantly now it's okay when
they do it right it's not okay when
anyone we're living in the and and I do
think that if it keeps up there will be
a massive shift in the Republican base
that will demand the same yes get burned
out they will start to say well we want
revenge right not we want revenge but we
recognize that I mean it's the if the
Democrat is acting like the bully right
every time you see a kid and the kid
wants to be a nice guy and he wants to
wants to wants to make peace and you and
you bludgeon him well then the kid goes
get gets five of his friends and then
they go okay well let's Ambush the bully
you know and kick him in the Shins
because what is the other way to stop
this right isn't it true that the
passivity of the right is provoking the
aggression of the left it goes on Fetter
there's no check to them
they are again uh they're totally
impossible to pacify every single time
you try to compromise with them or give
them a victory you're just encouraging
them more they're insatiable I've been
I've been saying this a bunch and
everybody that watches regularly has
heard me say it we are living in the
logic of Herbert Mark Hughes he wrote a
a paper called uh repressive tolerance
in the 60s and it essentially boils down
to it's okay when the left does it it's
and the right must be censored even at
the level of thought and that's the the
world that we live in now and you see it
all the time the way that the law is
applied to people with different
political opinions it is clear that it's
that it's being applied to conservatives
in a different conservatives and people
that are just outside of what is
acceptable uh opinion because you don't
have to be particularly conservative all
you have to do is push back against the
narrative we're going to go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net fringed documentary by
Lauren Southern it's amazing and I
recommend you share it with your friends
and family and I will say this right now
we strongly encourage if you've got a
local pub or hangout spot you can log in
and you can play that for everyone in
your neighborhood if you want to do
screenings please do so we think it's
fun we think it's entertaining and we
think it's important that this
perspective on the importance of our gun
rights and gun culture be shared with uh
with everybody and that's how we're
going to win that culture War but for
now we will read your super chats and of
course the first Super Chat we got is
Clinton Torres says howdy people Tim I
used to think the worst part about Star
Trek the Next Generation was Tasha y
dying but now I've been convinced it's
will weaton you know we were just
talking about that
yesterday and you know yeah sorry you
know will weaton just not I feel bad for
him because I feel like you know not for
who he is today but back then he gets
asked if he wants to play this role it's
supposed to be this super smart kid and
everyone hated the character and it's it
probably just it must suck to get
sidelined like that anyway Matthew
Hammond says Tim proposed a beef between
himself and Cassandra over Israel may I
recommend the names you call each other
Tim fence settler pool and Cassandra
West Banks McDonald haha yeah I tweeted
that I said hey Cassandra we should have
a fake beef over Israel to generate
press attention and people were like are
you implying that Ben and Kennis are
faking it and I'm like I'm implying it's
generating a lot of attention for them
I'm not I don't know if they're faking
it or not but I was like that's the joke
that I would be like Oh Cassandra how
dare you wo and then you know someone
said something like I'm I am unwilling
to call out Ben Shapiro for his obvious
like failures or whatever cuz I'm more
concerned with being friendly or friends
with him and I'm like I barely know Ben
chapiro we've interviewed him one time
I've talked to him a couple times and it
really just comes down to I don't know
or care enough about Israel to criticize
Ben Shapiro for like I I agree with a
lot of what Candace is saying about
America first but I'm not going to be
like well here's something I don't know
all that much about and I'm going to
come at you Ben or I'm back well i' love
to hear I think some people do that
because they're pretending like they're
doing the right thing but it actually is
for the engagement on Twitter not
everybody but I think that's sort of
what where the audience has gotten
confused it's not always
genuine I think I think also that some
of the imputation that that sort of Ben
is is not concerned about America
because he cares about Israel I think
that Ben genuinely believes that Israel
is The Outpost of Western civilization
in an extremely hostile region and that
the attack on Israel is part of a larger
attack on America and the West I think
he believes that sincerely and for the
most part I agree with him you know Mike
cernovich had a great twe I just
retweeted it where he said something to
the effect of imagine if the you see
these people that care so deeply about
Israel in this this you know this uh
this fervor imagine if Americans had
that same degree of fervor for America
and I I'm like I've been talking about
Israel Palestine derangement syndrome
where people just go to 11 instantly and
I'm like that's a really great point I I
would love it if people were instantly
had that fervor for the United States
unfortunately what do we get it's
Foreign Wars or it's nothing mhm yeah I
think it's also the case that that in in
the case of Israel and in the case of
Jews they do have a weapon that is not
available for example to whites which is
the anti-semitic weapon cuz cuz when the
left goes you're a settler you can play
back you're an anti-semite but let's say
someone comes and says you're a white
supremacist
you're uh you say I have black friends
exactly I had a black pres what are you
talking about I voted for Obama there
you go that's my all right Collision aov
says I purchased 10 of the black
paraplegic Santas from Target I'm I want
to why would you do that have you seen
this how is he going to get down your
chimney I don't understand Target is
selling uh white and black paraplegic
Santa ornaments oh so it's it's a black
Santa Claus and a white Santa Claus in
their in wheelchairs and so people are
like this is getting a little abs or
whatever my attitude has been like the
market shall provide if people want to
buy this like let them buy it and I got
to be honest I want to buy a bunch of
them and I'm willing to bet Target is
going to be like wow we're selling so
many of these people really love this
stuff look Tim Tim's got a point supply
side economics you didn't know that you
wanted an iPhone until the iPhone came
out I did not know I wanted Black Santa
suggesting that the Black paric Santa is
going to have the same effect on the
economy that the iPhone did can't I
didn't realize I needed it and now I
can't go anywhere think will happen to
Santa next year like does he get the CO
implant next year right does he like
transition I mean where go I'm going I
am going to look into a company that
manufactures stuffed figurines or
animals or whatever and see what we can
come up with and we are going to make
the woke collection Christmas ornament
series there is some Niche Etsy shop
that is like I need to find their email
immediately you know someone has been
doing this for a while of Reddit posts
where like I tweeted WTF how is this
real and it's funny because it does show
the isolation the left lives in because
the response from all these comments
where they were like I thought
Christians thought this I thought the
Bible said this and I'm sitting here
like I'm not a Christian like why are
they assuming because they don't know
anything about me they're probably wrong
about what the Bible says too oh for
sure and they're saying things like haha
Tim Po is so mad about mad I'm having a
blast I want to buy a bunch of them they
don't know anything about how I feel I'm
super excited for it if you want to
really flx them what you do in all these
situations is you attack them from the
left because if you think about if
you're a black s if you're a black
paraplegic Santa you have two claims to
intersectionality you're black that's
number one and you're paraplegic that's
number two but that still leaves three
or four so you're saying they should
make an accompany Mr Clause either that
either that or you cre create a group
that wants to boycott the black
paraplegic Santa on the grounds that
he's not diverse enough and then right
away is now now they're going to have to
get on a zoom call they're going to make
the the Mr claw companion
figurine no look look course Santa I'm
Legit I want to buy a bunch of these but
I would rather do our own timcast
collection and have a variety of options
like maybe you know
veteranus well sure we could do bcus but
I mean like making semi-real and semi
fake one just going all across the board
with it elves that have seen brutal war
and combat and you know PTSD triggered
PTSD
the reindeer having a rough time yeah
there's all kinds of stuff it is
interesting as a strategy for Target to
get conservatives to buy to break their
boycott right like make a ridiculous
item so they hate buy it someone had to
have known I don't know they are pretty
toned deaf though it's impossible to
tell I that's almost the genius Target's
not looking to break the boycott anyways
they hired someone for their they have
an LGBT Department apparently now and
and which is that I think they already
had that I don't know but the person
they hired is definitely uh someone that
conservatives would likely Brown upon
considering the uh history there now
let's read some more we got Jackie
Octavius says your conversation about
homelessness kind of surprised me it
makes sense though I'm living out of my
truck for work super cheap the
conversation we were having which has
now come up again in super chats is that
many of these leftists seem to think
that you can take a homeless person put
him in a house and problem solved
however the issue is that that's
technically the truth however that only
applies to homeless people who are
homeless by uh unfortunate circumstance
and are desperately trying not to be
whereas the reason you never encounter
that is because if somebody loses their
job and gets kicked out they instantly
go to a shelter and say I need help and
within a week or two they are placed
somewhere and not homeless anymore I
love that that's great for the
nonprofits but the people we see on the
streets in San Francisco and in in
Sacramento and Los Angeles and many
other places Chicago even they are
people who do not want to be in
buildings they want to be homeless so
there's no real solution to that except
for I guess forceful um removal or like
blocking of the homeless I want to know
when the nonprofit starts to get all of
the Millennials and zumers doing van
life houses you know they start being
like you guys technically qualify as
homeless will help you get a house and
then they look like they're doing a good
job because those people would probably
give it up easily I'm not your sorry I'm
not your buddy guy says denesh you did
an amazing job with police state and I
got to say even as a Canadian I was
moved by that ending we are in Dark
Times indeed so the ending he's talking
about and actually is thanks to Julie
here Julie in the movie talks about the
fact that the January 6 prisoners sing
the star spangle Banner at 900 p.m. in
an act of Defiance and patriotism so at
the closing of the movie I say uh in
honor of the January 6 political
prisoners and political prisoners around
the world this is actually I say um and
then we have a scene where you have one
guy in a cell and he starts to sing and
then a second guy joins and a third guy
joins into a kind of a a resounding
chorus but there's a sadness to it and I
think that's what really moves people
it's the star spangle Banner rendered in
a combination of Triumph and and
mourning mhm that's how the movie ends
all right Ian says shim cast is the best
not this timcast BS thank you I
appreciate that like check out I cut my
mic again this is censorship no I did to
myself thing I don't just want you to
compliment me I want you to degrade my
friends every when every nice comment
grman media says Crowder must be loving
this waiting for his show uh Crowder is
going to start his show with a an ish
eating grin and one arm on the table and
he's going to be looking at the camera
smiling something like that that's what
I predict all right all right here we go
the dude to bid says I like the daily
wire I like Ben but I'm siding with
Candace a lot of Ben's content has been
fanatical as of late with the current
conflict understandably he shouldn't
have snapped at Candace on social media
a lot of people I see on Twitter are
saying he Ben doesn't have the support
group to to pull him back a little bit
because he's the he's the he's the big
guy he's the boss he's got one of the
biggest podcasts he's the biggest
conservative podcaster I I'm pretty sure
his Show is bigger than basically any
other conservative podcast so uh you
know that may be that may be but uh look
man the dude didn't get where he is by
being bad at what he does I don't think
this is going to be the biggest thing
impacting the daily wire or Ben Shapiro
that's why when people are like why
won't you call out Ben or why why aren't
you telling Cassandra she can't say
these things and I'm like dude in three
months we're going to be talking about a
new book that came out was put in
schools America Matters substantially
more to me than what's going on Israel
but I'll always pretty much be an anti-
intervention and America first if you
Ben's show like it's not a surprise this
this his his attitude towards this like
it is it is completely predictable he's
he's always been pretty hawkish when it
comes to Israel so I mean if you don't
like that that's that's understandable
but like it shouldn't come as a surprise
to people that Ben's acting like this I
want to skip I want Serge if this is
your fault you're fired no I'm just
kidding it's me uh I want to skit on
what's happening in the dailywire HR
department right now like what kind of
mediation try to come out Zoom calls
there
yeah all right let's grab some more
Super chats what do we have
here um what is this what is this
Michael beacon says so crazy deap
followed the state's Christmas list of
groups and figures they hate despite
living in a house with BLM and antifas
signs all over it how about that how
about that and then he also got on the
stand and described in great detail his
conspiracy to go after other people who
are completely unrelated to his crime as
if to implicate him further for some
reason we get it we get it
all right what do we got Tron 54 says
can we please get a cartoon where
Candace interviews for a position with
timcast The Young Turks shoe on head and
ladder with Crowder ooh there might have
to be a cartoon about this whole ordeal
we've got so tomorrow's cartoon is going
to be hilarious and we have one planned
for next week too for Thanksgiving but
if people are still talking about this
um if people are still talking about
this by the time we have to do another
tune I I definitely want to try to
figure out an angle for it Sheamus and I
were colluding on a Christmas one on a
Christmas yeah there's this idea that I
had that I kind of pitched to Tim and
then he was he was coming up with ideas
for we were riffing on it like it's
super funny but I don't want to spoil
it it's yeah he was we were
like we'll have we'll talk more about it
after the show but it's going to be
super funny if we can do it that's when
Hannah Clair yelled at us yeah Hannah
Clair was I'm just to keep order here on
brim cast no I'm just kidding excuse us
let's read some more uh Ethan Helm says
Candace confidently but wrongly said
Muslims can only live in one area of
Jerusalem so Israel doesn't seem like a
very free place to her I think this is
the pseudo intellectualism Ben is mad at
not so much about her questioning on us
involvement uh no I agree I think you
know uh Candace has has said a lot of
things that are what basically what
people are saying is that when she posts
a Bible verse we know what she's
referring to and she said blessed are
the
peacemakers right now contextually it's
sounds like she's basically saying
ceasefire or something to that effect
for which Ben is like okay dude I know
what you're doing it is what it is it is
what it is or or I mean interestingly
when I first saw that post and
admittedly I haven't been following like
the blowby blow I interpreted completely
differently I actually interpreted that
that Candice was trying to mend fences
with Ben and and that the Blessed of the
peacemakers are like let's not let this
get out of hand I took it that way but I
now see that the possibility of reading
it in the AOC way which was it wouldn't
it be so brutal if Candace was actually
trying to make a statement about not
wanting to be mad with Ben
and per that's actually a fair point
perhaps what she was saying was she saw
the clip from Ben who said it's
disgraceful and then she said what am I
supposed to say to Ben and someone was
like nah blessed are the peacemakers I'm
going to Tweet blessed are the
peacemakers thinking that she was
basically saying I will not get into a
fight with you over this and then he got
no fight with her over it f and and then
U Shapiro tweeted back first Timothy
2:12 which is well we were it was the
verse like so women basically it's
actually about women not teaching in
church I I I don't need your your
hinging and explanations and P patter
I'd like you to read it it's going to
give taken down Sheamus is like so it's
1 Timothy 212 I do not permit a woman to
teach or to assume authority over a man
she must be quiet that's the yeah well
the context of it is Paul is writing to
Timothy at the church in Ephesus about
practices in church and this is
basically something that means women are
not supposed to be in the role of a
cleric they're not supposed to be
teaching in church or giving homilies
Sheamus is doing a struggle session
right now not augg no this is not a
struggle session Sheamus told me in
Catholicism to stop talking that he
wasn't going to take my great advice
that he solicited doesn't make any sense
he told you to hush in Catholic he
texted me first asked a question just
want to be clear so as to not give
Scandal the point is not to say women
can never teach or never teach people
the gospel it's to say they're not
supposed to teach they're not supposed
to be priests they're not supposed to
give homilies this is the public facing
Sheamus answer just say as soon as the
cameras go off it's a totally different
thing we we got a good a good Super Chat
here from Paul tascos he says daily wire
has proven Crowder was right he broke
the biggest story of the year the trans
Manifesto which Facebook Instagram
YouTube censored under dailywire
contract Crowder would have been
financially penalized for the best
journalism of
2023 that is a very very interesting
point the the man that was in January
whenever when this stuff went down and
the contract he showed or was it was the
terms sheet it wasn't the full contract
it was basically like are we going to
agree to these things said that he would
lose money if he got suspended or banned
or anything like that and uh that would
mean that he couldn't have done what he
did he would have had to have come
forward and say okay we well to be fair
he already lost money by releasing this
and getting these videos taken down he's
going to get hit all the same but it
would negatively impact his entire
contract which is probably more money
contract wise than straight up
advertising wise right he can he can
find ways to make up loss in that regard
but if his contract is his contract and
to penalize him there's no other there's
no increase you know yeah yeah I mean
the the economic model of of the daily
wirus is to is to pay you very well for
5 years and and to lock you into a
pretty long duration and then Moneyball
style to increase the value of your
brand in that time so that there's a
huge financial premium and it makes a
lot of sense I mean it's very smart
business from their point of view and
then when you leave you they've built
your brand up and they built your brand
up and you can take it with you
absolutely it's reminiscent of what
record labels do yeah I mean a record
label takes a band that they think
that's that's got something going and
they add money and promotion and
advertising the band goes out and and
however long the contract is some are
better some are worse but after a few
records or whatever if you if you
survive as a band and and become a
viable entity you can get off you can
decide to not sign another deal and
you've got a career that you've built
that the the record label it your career
would not be the same without the record
label almost every time like there are
some bands that that hit it off and and
do stuff without record label backing
but most of the time bands wouldn't get
to the level that they get to without
the record labels in the very beginning
so but how would you know about this you
failed musician uh you know 20 years 20
years of losing is what it is well but
but it is it's a very very different era
these days and so one of the most
difficult things is we want to do a
bunch of projects we go to someone and
say how would you like to like hey we've
seen your work it's really good would
would you like to do this job and they
go why well because we'll pay you money
and you can do I don't need it I'm on
YouTube I'm on Instagram I'm already
making money I got I got a patreon I've
got a you know subscribe start got my
own website and I'm like Fair Point
that's that's absolutely it uh there's a
very prominent YouTuber I was talking I
talk talking to who said that he does
all the work by himself for the most
part and his staff is mostly like
administrative paperwork and stuff like
that and I said wouldn't it be easier if
you just hired like a camera operator or
something and he was like man the amount
of money you have to pay to get someone
good enough to do the job is insane
because you have to pay them more than
they could make on their own by doing
social media which is then I'm going to
lose money by doing it that's one of the
things it used to be that you had and I
think back just to my early career if
when I was at AI the brand was AI the
brand was National Review so the
individual value of a writer at the
National Review was very low outside of
that club the key was to be in the club
um but now uh the brand is the
individual and so so as a result you
have individual brands with then a kind
of ancillary staff that enables the
individual to shine out front it's it's
very celebrity oriented this is why uh
I'll give a shout out to tenant media
we're we're doing the culture War
podcast now officially at tenet Friday
mornings and I don't want to speak too
much about their business and I think in
in time more will come out but basically
the general idea is bringing together a
whole bunch of personalities and it's
effectively a massive cross promotional
independent Network that I think is is
is going to be really really epic Benny
Johnson Dave Rubin me Taylor Hansen
Lauren Southern uh and a bunch of other
people super excited Matt Christensen
shout out we actually need a lot more of
this because what happens and a film is
a good example of this is that you we're
not big enough for the film to travel on
its own it needs allies one reason I
went to Dan Bonino I mean people go well
you went to Dan Bonino because he's a
former MD officer and he's a secret
service agent I go yeah but he also
happens to have a massive following and
so teaming up with bino takes my
following and takes Dan bino's following
and now we got a viable movie whereas
otherwise I'm traveling all on my own so
so right combining forces is important
so the thing with tennet and I'll just
say they're they're you know with like
Ruben and Benny Johnson they're they're
massive forces on their own as his
timcast and people are like why would
you do a show with a different network
because when Benny puts out a
documentary and we put out a culture War
then the people who watch culture war
and don't know Benny will then see his
his documentary and the people who watch
his documentary but don't watch us will
then see us and our Company still exist
it is created effectively like a a super
group band so uh that's how I kind of
thought about it when you have you know
these big bands and then a bunch of
different members form like a the
traveling Wilbur's or something I was
like I think this could be wildly
beneficial for everybody involved so
when it came together I was like this is
awesome I mean I I I see right here this
is the formula for getting for becoming
bigger than Fox News because Fox News at
one point was the pathway for every
conservative book every and then and
then when Fox News sort of went in a
took a kind of curved Road everyone was
left helpless including us I mean our
earlier films we were massively promoted
on Fox News uh and then they decided
because they're scared of election fraud
don't mention 2,000 mules and it now
carries over to police state not a
single fox show not a single Fox host
has mentioned the movie yeah foxes is
scared of a lot of stuff they're very
selective about who they yeah so it but
it creates a pressing need to build an
alternative Empire that is bigger than
Fox this may well be the recipe or at
least the the start of the recipe to do
it I've mentioned this on the show
before uh but it's almost as if at this
point what's happened is CNN tells you
what you're supposed to believe and then
Fox tells you what you're allowed to
believe so if you don't believe what CNN
believes you don't buy it all okay well
there's this other like limited category
of things you can believe but we don't
love it then once you're outside of the
fox territory now you're like a totally
radical conspiracy theorist are you
familiar with newsguard uh I've heard of
him sure the the the verification site
yeah we we use them all of our articles
whenever we read a story is News Guard
certified and the reason we do it is
despite having serious issues with them
is something fascinating happened when
they were trying to rate
timcast.net what criteria can we
determine whether or not something is
true or false and they immediately had
to backt trck and say okay well guess
it's true and it was like a hunter Biden
laptop thing that many in the mainstream
media were trying to claim was
disinformation and so uh what's
happening now they are being sued by
Consortium News Real Clear uh uh
politics just published this big article
about what's going on I my my I believe
right now it's relatively cursory but I
believe any organization that has ever
in any way worked with complied or
altered their their news uh at the
request of newsguard should be severed
from any kind of Public Funding News
Guard should be uh not allowed to to
contract so what happened is according
to this lawsuit the Pentagon has
actually contracted News Guard for
verification Services which means you
now have a government funded entity
which is determining what is true or
false in the public sphere like we saw
with the election Integrity partnership
this is crossing the line and violating
the First Amendment and I will clarify
timcast has told newsguard we will
comply with yourth e standards for a
good rating I said sure yeah absolutely
fine like I have no problem issing
Corrections however News Guard told us
because we ran a couple articles quoting
Donald Trump we were irresponsible and
would receive a strike for it and even
if we corrected them there there was
nothing so there was no correction our
stories were fact-based Donald Trump
holds rally says paragraph he did and
they said yeah but what he said in there
was not true and I said well that's fine
we weren't reporting whether on what he
said we we weren't reporting on the the
subject matter we're reporting on his
rally and his quote and they said
because we didn't fact check him we were
irresponsible and so then I said okay
from then we will we will we will uh
include that fact check and then we will
do moving forward and said we don't care
you're irresponsible we're going to give
you a strike meanwhile Consortium news
pointed out that with 20,000 articles
newsg guard had no problem except for
six articles and gave him a strike down
to 49% so my I just want to say this
right now I'm hoping that every single
news outlet that has been labeled by
News Guard
begins the process or however we do it
of a class action lawsuit for widespread
massive First Amendment violations and
uh defamation Lial Etc I mean look at
the look at the extent of the police
state thuggery involved right I mean
it's almost like in the old dictatorial
regimes it was really simple in the Nazi
regime you have a minister of propaganda
Geral he issues the press release and
everybody has to say the same thing and
if you don't you're going to be arrested
our police St I mean think about it the
censorship industry involves Academia
the media it involves the nonprofits the
digital
platforms innumerable agencies of the
government all operating in this kind of
like a octopus with like 18 tentacles so
rooting it out becomes more difficult
because you can't just get rid of gales
you've got to sort of go into this thing
and just like pull it apart well I think
that's too why there was such intense
blowback to any contradictory reporting
about January 6th because they really
believed that no one was going to
challenge that narrative that everyone
was going to fall in line this was an
Insurrection it should result in the end
of Donald Trump and the entire Maga
movement they really thought and I mean
the corporate media still is going along
with that so whenever you post something
or write something that exposes
something that they're covering up or
not reporting on uh they are hysterical
because they really thought after that
day they would impeach him they would
have the committee everyone you and a
lot of Republicans did fall in line and
now their whole narrative is collapsing
and so they're really struggling to to
maintain it keep it together that's why
they keep arresting people they need to
keep it in the headlines they they try
to save they try to save the essence I
mean right uh before 2000 mules my last
film it was deafeningly asserted in
every media out that the 2020 election
was the most secure election in US
history right and then as I went out
talking about that movie and and raising
simple questions like well if it was the
most secure election in history where's
the comparison of the amount of fraud
between 2020 and let's say 2016 2012
2008 show me that comparison that
someone has done showing me that the
2020 election had the least amount of
fraud not only has that never been
proven it's never been to my knowledge
attempted they said please stop talking
we said it was right what he said right
but then notice that after the film that
slogan has quietly dropped out of sight
they just don't use it anymore it's like
okay you got us on that one we're not
going to say it we're not going to take
it back we're not going to apologize
we're just going to not use that one
anymore but we'll try to preserve the
central idea that claims of election
fraud are baseless that's their favorite
word they're
baseless or not enough to overturn the
not enough to change the election there
was some but not enough to change the
election the election Integrity
partnership or whatever it was called so
we're now seeing that there was direct
government involvement in trying to
suppress opinions they called me a super
spreader of information and uh my
position has been exactly as you
described Bill bar said there was fraud
I think people have pointed out a lot of
instances of fraud but I don't know how
many of these lead to the actual this
election should have gone the other way
the most important thing is that a judge
listens to the lawsuits from Donald
Trump and his team and they're
adjudicated properly on the merits
that's always been my position
I what what I've always said is it
doesn't matter what you think happened
or who should have won Biden won why
he's in the white house so if you think
they played dirty I agree with you they
played dirty the shadow campaign all
that stuff that's been in the press my
position has always been like well
here's a lawsuit I wonder what the judge
will say for this the government
colluded with universities to silence my
speech lying about what I was saying the
mere thought that Donald Trump would
simply ask the question in court and ask
a judge to Ru the merits was so
threatening to them the this this is
insane to learn this the government we
had uh who was it on the show last week
they said you know that you're in these
documents right Tim and I know that they
released a report that included my name
and I got smeared in the Press by it all
over the place and I was shocked to see
this list that came out putting me in
like the top 15 or whatever super
spreaders of misinformation CU I'm like
but hold on all of my sources are
certified by newsguard I never said
Trump actually won the election not once
the mere thought that you would be like
oh okay let's see Trump's argument that
was too much you had to say in every way
Trump's wrong and he's lying and if you
didn't the government came after you but
uh we'll wrap it up there smash the like
button subscribe to this channel we're
going to we're going to figure out how
we're going to navigate the riots that
are going on outside they're not that
close let's go I'm not going to go
they're fighting cops uh there the uh uh
uh they're not that close but um you can
become a member at
timcast.net
not that far to drive we have a we have
about an hour to an hour and a half
drive back and then I got to be up at
7:00 in the morning again so I'm sorry
guys we just we wanted to come down here
far I'll say it's not it's not that bad
it's just by the time I get home and go
to bed I've got to wake up at 7:00 in
the morning so it's like we better we
better head back cut somewhere in the
week I want to do an after show you know
well we we going to do what we got to do
but but it's okay because Sheamus is
back and he's going to be here tomorrow
stream one on your iPhone put me on
we'll we'll live stream out the window
as we drive past the riots but uh you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me personally at timcast
everywhere Dan do you want to shout
anything out uh yeah I'm um uh police
state police state fm.net is the website
we're being blocked on Amazon and
Walmart so that's the place you can
stream it to your big screen TV you can
buy DVDs very good for gifts uh this is
a movie that will shake you up so I urge
you to watch it jul you want to shout
anything out I I'm just going to back up
what dases said check out the movie
because it is pretty mind-blowing are
you on X or anything can people follow
you guys yes I'm on X Twitter Julie _
Kelly 2 my substack Declassified with
Julie Kelly um all my reporting on Jan
on January 6th and my book on January 6
I just do think it's funny that everyone
says I'm on X now because of Elon mus
Twix I'm I'm on X baby Howes it's still
weird I like it I don't I still say
Twitter I don't know well I mean I feel
like I go back and forth well X doesn't
really have a verb right I mean you
still say I tweeted it out I posted I I
exed well but but you guys know what it
means to be on X yeah I me just occur to
me you can't really say I I I I exed
because it kind of sounds like sounds
yeah yeah or it's like you know you know
I got I got to mention um I was
skateboarding earlier with Taylor
Silverman and she was practicing a trick
and I said if I explained what you were
doing on social media I'd get banned
because of the terminology used by
skateboarders no no joke so uh the same
word you would use to describe the
transmission of a car a slang term which
you can't say on social media because
it's a slur is a term used in
skateboarding so skateboarders bust fat
lines or they do fat lines right so if
you were to lay out the full terminology
from a skatebo you are banned so fast so
anyway anyway everyone else shout stuff
out my name is Sheamus kogin I have a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes we
do uh animated cartoons and political
satire we have one coming out tomorrow
which I think is going to be really
funny so I'd like to ask you guys to go
over to Freedom tunes on YouTube you can
also find us at freedom tunes.com but go
over to the YouTube channel subscribe
hit the notification Bell uh if you
haven't seen it before check out some of
our videos I think you'll enjoy them
I'm Han Clair brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net team that set all the stuff
made it happen it's been so fun to be
here um if you want to and you
definitely should you should follow @
timcast news on whatever the social
media platforms are called if you want
to follow me personally I'm on Instagram
at hana. B I'm on whatever the other
one's called at HC brimo uh and yeah
just thank you guys so much thank you
both for being here and of course thanks
to Phil I am Phil that remains on Twix I
am Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
you can follow us on Spotify Apple music
Amazon music Pandora YouTube you know
the internet all right everybody thanks
for hanging out it was a blast coming to
DC hanging out at the Heritage
Foundation with thees doing his
screening of uh police state and we will
be back tomorrow with our members only
segment so watch infringed in the
meantime and we'll see you all
tomorrow